Exzellente
So ich bin mal wieder da
Hat ein bisschen gedauert ich bin noch nicht so 100 prozentig aber zu so 90 prozent fit das reicht erst mal
Es heißt morgen früh wieder ganz normal aufwacht streamen wobei ich glaube twitch hat noch gar nicht gecheckt dass es überhaupt los geht
Also morgen früh was also was heißt wahrscheinlich ziemlich sicher ganz normal aufwacht streamen wie immer
Letzten sonder hat das ganze nicht funktioniert
Ah jetzt hat's twitch gecheckt ja
Morgen ist dann alles am start hier der easy killer end of function 0 marbinski, koopa, fabian, kevtech, stripes und sie ich hab nicht heute geburtstag
Aber ich hatte geburtstag
Die letzten tage irgendwann
Und ich sag nicht genau wann aber ich hatte die letzten tage geburtstag
Stell euch mal vor ich bin jetzt 36
Kann man sich gar nicht vorstellen oder
Tier 1 subscription 13 monate easy clap, easy ist clap überhaupt
Ja ich brauche natürlich den discord um zu gucken weil ich geburtstagsab das ist logisch
Weird chap
So
Und
Es hat nicht so wirklich was mit meinem geburtstag zu tun
Aber ich hab mir die tage geburtstagsab gecheckt
Und es hat nicht so wirklich was mit meinem geburtstag zu tun
Aber ich hab mir gedacht nachdem ich ja die woche mir absolut gar nichts überlegt habe irgendwie was man im stream machen könnte
Ihr wisst ja ich war anderweitig da eingespannt ja und
Also ich mir gedacht morgen machen wir ganz normalen aufwacht streamen wie immer und heute abend
Schwätzen wir ein bisschen und ich kaufe ein paar sachen die ich mir schon die ganze zeit hol wollte
Ja das kann ich mir auch immer schlecht vorstellen ja was ist denn hier los jetzt auf einmal
Das das kamar strain ist am start
Set pudding
Tier 1 sechs monate
Exzellent dankeschön und wen haben wir sonst noch esort drei monate
subscriptions
reingeflohen
Und das gem train ist auch am start easy as fuck
So
Keine großartig teuren sah wobei wobei ja doch ein paar ein paar bisschen teurere sachen sind drinne leute ich weiß
Weird flex und so meine karte für die sparkasse war kaputt
Und also ich habe ja ich habe ja zwei
Konten einmal hier youtube twitch gedöns
Und einmal
privates zeug ja
Und meine sparkasse karte war kaputt das heißt ich habe die letzten drei monate oder so nix abgehoben
Weil ich zu faul war erste neu zu beantragen
Dann haben die irgendwie noch drei wochen gebraucht bis ich was neues gekriegt habe und so so wenn sie ja wieder hatte
Wieder ewig lang gedauert und ich konnte jetzt in die letzte woche auch nicht zumindest
Ich war heute mal wieder abheben
Ein bisschen kohle ja und mich hat der schlag getroffen was da einfach rumgammelt auf so einem publischen
Sparkassenkonto mittlerweile ich ich bin echt sparsam es fällt mir immer wieder auf bei sowas
Wenn ich mir was kaufe dann kaufe ich immer gescheites zeug aber ansonsten kaufe ich nichts ich mein gut ich für was
Für was brauche ich auch geld ich habe kein auto ich mache hier keine großartig ich fahre nicht irgendwie großartig ins ausland
Ich kaufe wieder drogen noch besaufe ich mich ja versuche ich nicht
Ich habe kein auto ich mache hier keine großartig ich fahre nicht irgendwie großartig ins ausland ich kaufe wieder drogen noch besaufe ich mich
Ja wo soll die skola auch hingehen ja
Easy twitch money, das twitch money ist auf dem anderen konto. Ohbei lass mal überlegen das twitch money
Das twitch money könnte sogar auf paypal sein
Weird flex ja
Musste erst mal einen fetten bmw kaufen nee das kaufe ich mir im leben nicht kaufen ich sehe es überhaupt nicht ein ich
Ich habe da überhaupt kein anwendungszweck ich kann es auch gar nicht verstehen
Die ganzen anderen da die dir teilweise auf youtube passt das erste was du da siehst ist sobald ein bisschen was rumgekommen ist
erst mal fettes
Flex video mache mit dem neuen auto und sowas
Verkehrs wozu ja
Ja das soll war
Dann gehts von die kohle los
Komm doch mal ein bisschen drauf an
Ja aber ansonsten ich weil es geht ja für nix kohle runter irgendwo
Irgendwann kratze ich mal ab
Und hat massig geld übrig und weiß nicht was ich damit machen soll
Und dann
Färbe ich es keine ahnung
Färbe ich es keine ahnung dem tierheim
Oder etwas
Weil ich habe nach wie vor nicht vor irgendwie killers zu bekommen also ich hasse kinder kinder gehen mir so sehr auf den sack
Ich will keine
Nie
Der chat erbt das geld ich weiß nicht ob das so eine gute idee ist für den chat
Ne ne ne ne ne
Ne chat das
Das funktioniert umgedreht
Ich bekomme geld vom chat
Und nicht der chat von mir
Der chat bekommt ab und zu mal ins ab
Gegiftet dass der chat das gefühl hat dass sie irgendwas passiert oder so
Ansonsten ist das falsch rum
Ne ne chat so ist das nicht gedacht
Mit 50 in rente
Ja das hat ohne mist ich mache mir da schon eine weile drüber Gedanken wie lang ich wirklich arbeiten gehen will
Also wollen wollen gar nicht ja
Aber
Also ich habe nicht vor ich habe letztens wieder mein rentenbescheid da gekriegt wo drin steht man kriegt ja immer so ein rentenbericht
Irgendwie sowas keine ahnung wie sich das nennt so ein so ein zettel kriegt man ja immer
Ja sowas hier
Kriegt man immer das steht drauf was ich kriege und das ist so wenig
Das ist so wenig was du gesetzlich an rente kriegst ist der witz das ist der komplette witz
Ich habe es jetzt ich habe es jetzt nicht im kopf großartig ich glaube
Irgendwas um 2000
Also ich gehe also da steht drauf in rente gehe ich irgendwann
2000 also offiziell wenn man das erreicht hat 2057 oder irgendwie sowas
Und und ich krieg dann irgendwie 2000 euro oder so wenn du überlegst
Ich krieg dann nach was weiß ich wie vielen jahrzehnten einbezahlt
Weniger
Ganz als ich jetzt kriege mit vier tage die woche ab also das ist ja fast nichts und vor allem das sind 2000 euro dann im jahr
2057 oder irgendwann da kannst du dir dann wahrscheinlich so viel von kaufen wie von heute für 1000 das ist doch der witz
Also gesetzliche rente kannst du ja mal komplett klicken
Investiert ein geld in bitt connect euer bitt connect ist natürlich die passende investment das gehe ich so ein
Es ist wirklich totaler witz es gibt nix im endeffekt und
Ich sehe das jetzt schon kommen
Wenn also ich habe letztens ich habe doch letztens ein video drüber geguckt das klaut klang klang sehr sehr plausibel
Also ich weiß ja ich bin ja der übelst krasse finanz guru kommt in meine telegram gruppe und sowas aber ich habe da letzten video drüber geguckt das klang
wirklich ziemlich sinnvoll was der erzählt hat über
private renten
vorsorge gedöns und zwar hat er gesagt im video
Gucken wir das morgen mal gucken das fand ich die fand ich echt nicht schlecht dass das hat eine fünf minuten gedauert und zwar hat gesagt
Dass die leute die jetzt irgendwie private renten
Ich kann das jetzt schreiben
Rentenversicherung die irgendwie eine private rentenversicherung abgeschlossen haben dass das problematisch wird weil und ich finde das klang plausibel
weil es jetzt aktuell so ist dass die ganzen versicherungen 90 prozent 95 prozent
Nur leute haben die einbezahlen
Also und es werden dann in den nächsten 30 jahren
Innerhalb von fünf bis zehn jahren von diesen 90 prozent zahlen ein zu 90 prozent wollen haben
Quasi umgewandelt werden und er hat gesagt er ist echt
skeptisch wie viele
wirklich ihre rente bekommen unterm strich wenn es dann soweit ist
Ich meine klar es gibt irgendwelche großen versicherungsdinger da will ich mir weniger gedanken machen aber da meinte auch es könnte durchaus sein dass das einige nicht
überleben und im endeffekt gar nichts hieß
Ich meine ist ja auch irgendwo klar
Wenn das wirklich innerhalb von fünf bis zehn jahren sich dreht von 90 prozent zahlen ein zu 90 prozent wollen haben
Aber es kommt immer mehr nach die wieder einzahlen ich glaube nicht dass das in die gleiche kasse geht
Außerdem außerdem sind es weniger leute die einbezahlen ja
Ich bin mal gespannt also ich mache mir da recht wenig gedanken wie gesagt ich krieg meine publik
Rende wo ich letztes bescheid zu gekriegt habe
Ich krieg dann irgendwie 200 prozent
2000 euro irgendwie im jahr fragt mir nicht 2050 oder und da krieg ich noch von
Das einzige was halt gute ist dass wenn der betriebliche altersvorsorge haben wurde arbeitgeber mit einbezahlt das ist auch noch ok und bis dahin ganz ehrlich
Ich gebe so wenig geld aus bis dahin habe ich genug kohle dass ich easy den ganzen scheiß nicht brauche zumal ich noch ein haus habe
Ich muss noch nicht mal so ein haus haben
Da mache ich mir keine gedanken drüber aber wo ich mir echt gedanken macht sind
Wenn ich die leute teilweise hier sehe am bahnhof
Das sind so viele rentner mittlerweile dabei jetzt nicht nur bei uns am bahnhof an ganz vielen bahnhöfen da sind so viele rentner mit mittlerweile unterwegs
Das gab es früher nicht ich weiß ich so richtig boomer logik das war früher besser oder so das will ich damit gar nicht sagen aber es gab früher
Nicht so viele rentner die am bahnhof gestanden haben wegen wegen essen wegen flaschen wegen geld sammeln
So dass ich genau das seit ich was den renter noch übrig bleibt müssen auf twitch streamen gehen die machen es dann so die machen es dann so wie willhelm kramer lp
Oder wieder wie ist da hallo meine freunde
Hab ich irgendwas übersehen hier
Oh ja guck mal hier foggets kinder ja wahrscheinlich wenn es die eigenen sind sieht man das dann anders ja da hast du wahrscheinlich recht
Danke für den sub dann haben wir hier noch taste twitch prime zwei monate dankeschön subscription
Zu einem geburtstag kann ich das anklicken
Besser nicht ja so wo habe ich denn jetzt habe ich irgendwas übersehen phoenix am start moin zwölf monate hyper subscription ist das ja schon
Geben wir mal ein bisschen was hier
Phoenix am start moin zwölf monate hyper subscription ist das ja schon
Geh die kono
Auch fünf monate am start dankeschön
Endes sicher
Naja so aber genug genug da rum ja wieder gesund ja also 90 prozent 90 prozent ist gut 90 prozent ist gut
Ja das stimmt da hat er kupa recht
Da habe ich ja da habe ich auch habe ich jetzt gar nichts zu gesagt
Du musst ja jetzt schon teilweise rente versteuern und wir eh also wir haben
Wir haben wir haben wir haben die arschkarte also ist es nicht nur so dass wir nicht schon steuern bezahlt haben wir müssen dann wenn wir die rente
Bekommen nochmal steuern bezahlt es ist eh vorbei es ist eh vorbei alles
Nein mache ich nicht aber
Ich würde ich würde gerne insofern dass ich
So finanz stonks zeug ist für mich übelst anstrengend
Das ist ein thema das interessiert mich absolut gar nicht das ist wirklich für mich so ein so extrem ätzendes
ätzendes thema
Aber
Es ist was wo ich mir wo ich hoffe dass ich irgendeinem finanz themenbereich mal was
Abgewinnen kann wofür ich mich interessiere
Sodass ich mich damit interessieren kann
Vielleicht aber irgendwas mit meiner kohle mache aktuell ist die kohle einfach nur am start und und
Das einzige was ich mache
Allerdings nicht an nicht random irgendwie an jeden oder so ich habe ein paar leuten geld geliehen
Mit mit teilweise zinsen wo ich mir denke das ist schon fast fast fies aber ich habe es mir nicht ausgesucht das wollten die leute selbst
Aber es ok das soll mir recht sein ja
Aber ansonsten ist das natürlich auch eine sache wenn ich das nicht wieder kriegt dann habe ich gelitten
Na ja gut aber das ist ein thema da kann echt wenig zu sagen
Was hältst du von singplatz beziehungsweise ist beste es gibt also gibt kaum bessere
So also ich wollte ein paar sachen noch kaufen wie gesagt hatte letzten tage geburtstag hat damit eigentlich nur am rande was zu tun
Du leihst geld für zinsen ja mache ich aber nur bekannten also nur leute ich kenne und
Wo ich weiß dass die chancen dass ich wieder kriege recht hoch sind ja
Der finanztipp.de ok
So und ich habe mir gedacht ich muss mir immer wieder ein paar sachen bestellen da mache ich das jetzt einfach im stream
Weil ich die woche nur wirklich andere sachen im kopf hatte als technik content für stream vorbereiten
Mit vertrag immer mit vertrag choose my name immer mit vertrag
Mündliche absprache ist schön und gut aber immer mit vertrag da gibt es da mittlerweile schöne form vor vordrucke
Wo man nicht wirklich viel machen muss
Außer eintragen wer wer das unterschreibt und bis man was wieder kriegt
Und auch in welche art und weise
Wie ich habe auf der arbeit einer ist der hat so ein bisschen verschwörungstheorie mensch
Der erzählt öfters was auf merkwürdige dinge aber letztens hat er mir auch wieder erzählt im teams
Hat er mir auch wieder erzählt ja also max ich kaufe jetzt gold ich kaufe nur noch gold
Und aber nicht einfach nur einfach nur gold sondern er geht immer direkt dort wo das gold geschmolzen wird hin und kauft sich dort gold
Weil dort wird nicht erfasst wer das gold gekauft hat
Das ist das ist mal next level weil er sagt ok wenn die mit das ist man merkt halt dass es übelst verschwörungstheorie in form ist
In form von weil er immer weil er immer sagt die
Der sagt die ganze zeit die und
Da hat er letztens erzählt so nach dem wortel ja dann kriegen die das nicht mit dass ich gold gekauft habe wenn mal irgendwann
Sachen gefändet werden habe ich mein golden die wissen nicht dass ich gold gekauft habe
Irgendwann Sachen gefändet werden habe ich mein golden die wissen nicht dass ich gold habe
Der ist der ist ein bisschen empfänglich für so verschwörungstheorie geschichten der ist zum beispiel auch der meinung dass
Die sonnen aktivität allein dafür verantwortlich ist dass es wärmer geworden ist die letzten 60 jahre
Ist das das haus mit dem aufzug im atelier ja richtig
Schenkt dem typ zum geburtstag ein 5g bioschild. Oh ja das
Gibt sie dinger noch zu kaufen das wäre echt gute idee die sind viel zu teuer kaum ich überleben
So das kamas scheiße alter ich glaube ich habe es euch schon mal gezeigt
das 5g bioschild
Es gibt natürlich auch wieder testimonials wo sie alle sagen wie geil das ist
Big difference
Having one in our computers ok ok das problem ist doch wenn das doch also erst mal erst mal erst mal erst mal
5g hat mit mit wi-fi nichts zu tun
Aber allein schon an der stelle sollte es ihm einleuchten dass das nix miteinander zu tun hat weil wenn das wi-fi am computer noch geht
Da kann das schild ja schon mal nicht funktionieren
Wie soll das schild funktionieren wenn es 5g schildet aber das aber aber 5g am computer
Also das müsste ja den blödesten verschwörungstheorie mensch einleuchten dass das keinen sinn ergibt
Mit diesem verschwörungs der kann man reibach machen
Sagt star meg ja gibt es ja genug gibt ja genug gibt es doch jetzt den typ wo mich letztens ich habe schon wieder verlesen
Attila attila irgendwas wo ihr mich letztens im stream gefragt hat ob ich den kennen wo ich gesagt habe
Nee, kenne ich nicht und ich habe nach dem streamer geguckt was das für einer ist das ist irgendeiner
Irgendein koch
Irgendein veganer koch der jetzt ultra verschwörungs theoretiker geworden ist
Ich habe ein paar sachen angeguckt alter
Ich sag ja immer im stream dass
Man sollte nicht alles verschwörungs theorie nennen sofort ja also nur weil einer kritik an irgendwas übt sollte man nicht automatisch sagen
Aller verschwörungs theorie
Aber mit was für dingen der teilweise ankommt da fällt mir auch nichts anderes mehr ein
Da fällt mir letztens hatten sie irgendwie erzählt große
Corona-gegner-demonstration in berlin es waren irgendwie keine 20.000 leute da
Was echt schon viel ist überlegt euch mal 20.000 leute ist
Ist ordentlich ja ist nicht einfach dass das da fünf anzel oder so rumrennen 20.000 leute so aber 20.000 leute
10.000 leute oder 10.000 ich vollkommen egal sagen 20.000 ist nicht genug ist nicht genug
Dann haben dann hat der typen ein video gemacht
Wo er und noch irgendwie so eine verschwörungs theorie frau zusammen vor der kamera standen nachts irgendwie im dunklen haben gesagt
Ihr werdet wieder alle angelogen 20.000 es waren 1,3 millionen
Leichte diskrepanz dazwischen
Also die haben alle bis in den dachschaden aber kommen wir mal zu all zu erfreulicheren sachen zurück
Das ist ein guter punkt hier
Coupa schreibt ich habe sowieso das gefühl dass wir was aufklärung gerade einen schritt zurück machen kann kann aber auch sein dass man durch das internet
Einfach mehr von solchen mitkriegt beides oder eigentlich sind es drei sachen denke ich zumindest
Ich glaube nicht dass wir wirklich einen rückschritt machen aber aktuell ist information overkill
Und es gibt studien dazu dass leute die von was überzeugt sind wenn sie
Umso klarer sie belegt bekommen dass das nicht stimmt umso mehr glauben sie da dran
Dann hast du einmal die leute die eh schon davon überzeugt sind und dann hast du leute die totalen informations
Overkill haben die auch viele sachen gar nicht erklärt bekommen können oder auch sachen nicht erklärt bekommen und dann ist es ja ziemlich einfach zu sagen
Okay, die die wahrheit oder was heißt die weit die realität ist übelst komplex und kompliziert
Ist die welt ist halt nur nicht schwarz und weiß aber auf der anderen seite habe ich verschwörungstheorie mensch der mir das in fünf sätzen erklären kann ja
Dann bin ich da schon geneigt an die ganze sache da glaube ich lieber da dran
Und ja man kriegt auch mehr mit von solchen leuten
Ja naja aber
Das ist ein problem
Und das ist auch der grund warum ich der meinung man sollte nicht zu allen verschwörungstheories theoretiken also man sollte nicht alles verschwörungstheorie nennen
Schrödinger sechs monat dankeschön
Was hältst du von pep link geräten habe ich schon nie gehört
Das ist denn pep link ich glaube gibt es nicht keck link
Keck link gibt es gibt es keck link
Und es gibt keck link okay ich habe keine ahnung was es ist
Keine ahnung sagt mir nix klingt nach irgendwelche netzwerk geschichten sagt mir null
Ne echt keine ahnung ja eine sache bevor wir jetzt bevor wir sachen einkaufen was ich jetzt noch fertig oder was ich noch fertig sagen wollte
Ich bin der meinung man sollte nicht alles verschwörungstheorie nennen bloß weil es einem nicht in kram passt sondern man sollte den leuten erklären
Warum sachen passieren das ist insofern recht wichtig zum beispiel bei den ganzen coronamaßnahmen die wir aktuell haben
Gibt es ja gibt es jetzt einige die sagen das schränken ihre grundrechte ein und was ich auch nicht ganz verstanden habe ist warum man für warum man
Bei corona nicht demonstrieren darf aber bei black lives matters schon klar es sind zwei komplett unterschiedliche paar sachen aber irgendwo muss alles für alles gelten sonst ist das ja auch irgendwie
Schwammig das ganze ja deshalb das habe ich nicht so genau verstanden aber man sollte nicht man sollte nicht zu allem nicht zu allem verschwörungs
Verschwörungstheorie sagen weil du musst den leuten schon ein bisschen erklären warum sachen passieren also zum beispiel wenn jetzt gesagt wird ok
Also wenn es die regierung sagt man entscheidet sich für das und das von der nennen wir es mal von der freiheit soll eingeschränkt werden wegen corona
Dann ist es wichtig dass man das die regierung oder der pressesprecher oder wer auch immer dass sie dass man nicht einfach nur sagt leute es ist so
Sondern dass man den leuten erklärt und das ist finde ich das was an vielen stellen nicht passiert und das eigentlich entscheidende
Und das ist auch das mein kritikpunkt an dieser ganzen corona
Das corona handlings dass die sachen nicht ausreichend erklärt werden
Also sprich man müsste eigentlich erklären ok wir entscheiden uns jetzt für
Lösungen a
Was auch immer das ist so und wir haben uns dafür entschieden weil es gab die und die punkte zur auswahl weil nur wenn man es nachvollziehen kann
Weil nur wenn man es wurde kaum was erklärt
Es würde es wurde nein es wurde nie erklärt wie man zu den maßnahmen gekommen ist oder nur ganz vereinzelt es wurde kaum erklärt
Es wurde erklärt so nach dem motto ja corona
Verbreitung ansteckungsgefahr sonst was es wurde relativ viel informiert über den virus an sich aber wie die entscheidungsträger
Zu den entscheidungen gekommen sind
Das wurde so gut wie nicht erklärt und das ist ein punkt den könnte ich verstehen als kritiker ok wie seid ihr denn jetzt zu der entscheidung gekommen dass zum beispiel
ladengeschäfte über so und so viel
Quadratmeter dürfen keine leute reinlassen unter so und so viel quadratmeter sprich wie seid ihr auf diese grenze gekommen das sind so sachen
Wie kommt man darauf ja oder man hat sich dazu entscheiden ja ok demonstration oder zusammenkünfte von leuten mit so und so viel gruppen bis zu dieser anzahl
Darf man drüber darf man nicht
Wie ist man zu dieser zahl gekommen also sprich transparenz das was kooper sagt das ist so gut wie nicht passiert
So und nur nur wenn du das den leuten sinnvoll erklärst und man es nachvollziehen kann dann kann man auch überzeugt sein davon
Ansonsten wenn du das nämlich nicht machst wenn du das nicht machst
Dann bietest du gerade näherboten für irgendwelche verschwörungstheoretiker weil dann kannst du nämlich sagen ok
Die schaffen es nicht mal richtig zu erklären warum sachen warum entscheidungen getroffen werden
Und auf der anderen seite hast du ihn verschwörungstheorie mensch der sagt ja das ist china das ist bill gates das ist corona das ist new world order was auch immer
Und das sagen die leute aha ich wusste es das ist es deswegen erklärt uns auch keiner
Und was ist das eigentliche problem es ist natürlich würden erklärungen helfen erklärungen würden würden viel überzeugungsarbeit leisten
Es ist nicht das problem dass man das macht es ist die die willkürlichkeit an der ganzen sache also sprich warum darfst du dich nur bis zu
einer gewissen anzahl leute treffen warum darfst du dies war wie ist man dazu gekommen das ist der eigentliche punkt es ist ungefähr so
Wie wenn euer chef zu euch kommt und sagt hier ab morgen kriegt er weniger geld unabhängig davon ob das mit eurem arbeitsvertrag vereinbar ist oder nicht
So die entscheidung ist unumstirchlich euer chef sagt ok ab morgen gibt es weniger geld und tschüss fressen oder stirbt
Das ist die eine variante oder aber euer chef kommt zu euch und sagt leute ab morgen gibt es weniger geld die firma hat starke finanzielle
Schwierigkeiten wir müssen wir müssen eventuell konkurs anmelden blablabla euer chef erklärt euch ihr findet es in beiden fällen nicht gut dass ihr weniger geld
kriegt aber die zweite entscheidung könnt ihr in gewisser weise mittragen und könnte seid ihr zumindest im bilde was sache ist das ihr könnt das
nachvollziehen und nur wenn ihr was nachvollziehen könnt könnt ihr zumindest davon überzeugt sein dass nicht einfach willkürlich
irgendwelche entscheidungen getroffen werden das heißt das ist das ist ein punkt den ich an vielen stellen kritisieren nicht nur bei den
corona bei den ganzen corona maßnahmen dass viele sachen nicht richtig erklärt werden
man muss den leuten erklären warum sachen passieren warum sachen gemacht werden
so und das passiert nicht und gerade das finde ich gibt eben vielen leuten hat so ein bisschen leere bei den leuten zurück
wo dann jemand um die ecke kommt und sagt ja es ist china 5g bill gates und dann sagen die achso ja logisch ja was soll es denn sonst sein
deswegen erklärt es mir auch keiner
ja also ich glaube man kann es jetzt ungefähr nachvollziehen was ich meine und wir müssten an eigentlich müssten an vielen stellen die sachen deutlich
genauer erklärt werden weil wann wann gibt es wirklich erklärungen dafür nachvollziehbare erklärungen wie entscheidungen
zustande gekommen sind so gut wie nicht es wird manchmal vordergründig irgendwas zusammen gedichtet so nach dem motto ja das ist jetzt
alternativlos und das geht nicht anders aber wie ist man denn dazu gekommen das ist das eigentliche problem dabei ich will wissen wie man zu
irgendeiner entscheidung gekommen ist da kann ich das ganze auch nachvollziehen und kann ich auch sagen ok ich finde die entscheidung zwar nicht gut
ich hätte auch lieber was anderes ja aber ich kann zumindest den gedankengang nachvollziehen warum man das gemacht hat weil ansonsten
bleibt dir ja nichts anderes übrig wie übliches stammtisch gelaber weil du hast ja keine ahnung im endeffekt so nach dem motto stammtisch gelaber
insofern man weiß es ja eh schon besser alles deppen die sachen entscheiden und garantiert nicht ich wette mit euch die haben sich alle um die
meisten sachen wurden sich relativ viel gedanken gemacht aber sofern man nicht die beweggründe erfährt kann man es nicht nachvollziehen
guck mal hat uns jemand schlüssig artikel 13 erklärt falls ich da noch jemand dran erinnert hat uns das irgendjemand schlüssig erklärt
warum man das wie man jetzt dazu gekommen ist auf die idee dass das gut ist
einige maßnahmen waren halt einfach aus dem gefühl heraus ich glaube nicht dass einfach aus dem gefühl heraus irgendeine quadratmeter grenze oder so
entlasten wird da wurde mit sicherheit darüber diskutiert und wenn das auch auf grund von irgendwelchen gefühlen passiert da müssen wir zumindest
die ganze sache einordnen und sagen ok die und die sachen liegen uns vor und uns erscheint aus diesen und diesen gründen das vorgehen jetzt am besten
dann weißt du bescheid dass das ist ganz großer punkt der mir bei vielen politischen entscheidungen auf den sack geht dass es so gut wie keine transparent gibt
ihr müsst euch mal interviews angucken oder sind ja keine interviews diese fragetermine zu pressekonferenzen so nach dem motto es werden neue sachen vorgestellt
da wird oftmals einfach nichts beantwortet da werden fragen gestellt und es besteht keinerlei pflicht da irgendwie inhaltlich drauf einzugehen das ist der totale witz
du kannst die pressekonferenz auch komplett sein lassen ja hat sich da einer mal hingestellt wirklich versucht zu erklären warum er das für sinnvoll findet
weil die wussten genau das ist ein unliebsames thema
und wenn man den leuten nichts erklärt und den leuten nichts nachvollziehen können dann wundert es mich nicht dass immer mehr verschwörungs theoretiker und abstruse
theorien der zulauf bekommen das ist einfach du hast auf der einen seite die komplexität der aktuellen welt und du hast auf der anderen seite eine total einfache
erklärung china 5g bill gates oder irgendwas in der richtung und natürlich sagen dann leute ok wenn ich sie richtig erklärt kriege wenn ich da nicht durchblicke mein gehirn anstrengen ist zu kompliziert
ich bin zu low brain 3 hat was auch immer dann gucken wir uns jetzt frag mich nicht attila hilde mann oder so an und zack hast du neun verschwörungs theorie mensch mehr
und das problem dabei ist dass gerade die leute die dort erstmal mit anfangen um umso länger die dabei sind das heißt umso länger umso engagierter die dabei sind
umso schlechter kannst du leute da wieder davon überzeugen dass das blödsinn ist umso besser du es begründest umso mehr überzeugt sind sie davon dass es nicht stimmt
dass sie recht haben das heißt du müsstest quasi schon vorbeugen dass eben leute weniger gründe haben dort mitzumachen so ich habe jetzt gar nicht chat gelesen ich habe jetzt viel zu viel erzählt
ich wollte eigentlich wollte ich ja was einkaufen anstatt mich da drüber auszulassen also ich scroll mal kurz hoch ob ich irgendwas im chat übersehen habe so
wissen was ich übrigens voll verwirrend finde dass es 2,4 gigahertz wehland gibt 5 gigahertz wehland und jetzt 5g was mit gigahertz gar nichts zu tun hat
sondern irgendwie fragt mir nicht 40 gigahertz ist weil es generation 5th generation ist es wird ein benahmung kaos ich habe musenik 12 monat dankeschön excellent subscription
falls ich irgendwas übersehen habe tut es mir leid
noch eine sache zu dem was mike cunfly gesagt hat es geht nicht darum dass man alles erklärt aus wissenschaftlicher sicht sondern man soll seine entscheidungen erklären warum man sie getroffen hat
und das ist es ist auch eine erklärung zu sagen ok die aktuellen wissenschaftliche ergebnisse deuten darauf hin es sieht so und so aus deswegen entscheiden wir uns das so und so zu machen das ist ja ok du musst ja nicht alles 100 du kannst eh kaum was 100 prozent erklären
muss aber erklären warum die entscheidung wie getroffen wurde wie stehst du eigentlich zur legalisierung von cannabis bin ich dafür komplett
wenn das legalisiert wäre hätte ich morgen hätte ich wenigstens was für mein garten könnte ich endlich was anpflanzen
weibnation wahrscheinlich würde ich da auch nicht sonderlich viel konsumieren aber ich bin komplett dafür dass es legalisiert wird ich finde auch ich erkenne auch dort wieder wo wir gerade bei der sache sind erklärt ich erkenne dort auch den die begründung nicht
ich erkenne dort auch keine sinnvolle begründung warum es nicht legalisiert wird vor allem in anbetracht der tatsachen dass halt eben wenn du dir manche medikamente anguckst die du frei nehmen kannst wenn du dir vielleicht die üblichen sachen mit zigaretten alkohol sonst was anfangen das ist alles schädlicher als wenn sich irgendeiner mal ein joint reinhaut
zumal du kannst ja daran auch nicht mal wirklich sterben ich weiß nicht was du dir für eine menge reinhauen müsstest dass du daran stirbst
ich glaube du kannst dir gar keine wirklich überdoses damit reinhauen oder wahrscheinlich müsstest du dann irgendwie was rauchen was von hier was so lang wie der messeturm in frankfurt ist oder so also wenn es an mir geht können sie das besser gestern als heute machen
willst du eine offizielle stellung ja natürlich aber die gibt es ja meistens auch ja es gibt also was ich dazu gelesen habe interviews ich habe mal ein interview gesehen mit
irgendeiner drogen beauftragten oder so ich hätte absolut zusammenhangloses zeug erzählt das hat mich nicht überzeugt
aber wie gesagt ich bin da dafür aber jetzt gehen wir ein paar sachen einkaufen zwar das ding wollte ich schon die ganze zeit mal ausprobieren
excellent so genau also ich muss meine einkaufsliste kurz aufmachen es sind ein paar teure sachen dabei aber das ding wollte ich schon lange mal ausprobieren weil ihr wisst ja ich habe im keller aktuell ein esp 32 hängen
der ist an den beiden stromzählern dran und liest die aus aber bald wird mein stromzähler ausgetauscht habe ich gehört ein kollege von mir da wurden um die ecke so 400 meter luftlinie weg bei dem sind sie gerade dabei dass der nächste stromzähler ausgetauscht wird
das bedeutet das ist das ist so richtiger fail na das ist richtiger fail aktuell sind wir so richtig old school haben noch sowas hier im keller falls es überhaupt noch jemand kennt das ist der boomer der boomer counter so ein teil vielleicht hat der eine oder andere bei der oma sowas schon mal gesehen oder so also sowas haben wir aktuell noch im keller und ich habe so ein bisschen was in dieser richtung hier gebaut um das aus zu
um das auszulesen ich habe da so einen sensor der erkennt wenn das rote ding durchläuft der kommt demnächst weg so
was ich jetzt leider ein bisschen doof finde ist es gibt jetzt einen neuen stromzähler allerdings ist das so eine ganz merkwürdige geschichte ich bin mal gespannt wann die bei uns wirklich auf aufschlagen das erste was ich gehört habe ist wie gesagt ich kann ich kenne es nicht aus erster hand bei mir waren die noch nicht
ich kenne das bloß von einem der nicht weit von mir weg wohnt wo sie das machen wollen und zwar das erste was sie eben erzählt haben ist dass der neue stromzähler an seine fritzbox dran soll und ganz ehrlich liebe stadtwerke das könnt ihr bei mir vergessen
ich lasse euch im leben nicht an meine fritzbox dran ich lasse euch im leben nicht an mein netzwerk dran da könnt ihr absolut das könnt ihr absolut vergessen das könnt ihr absolut vergessen also anscheinend ist es jetzt so dass diese neuen zähler zählen allerdings man selbst kann sie nicht richtig auswerten
also sprich die schicken den zähler stand wohl auf irgendeine art und weise heim wenn es nicht über netzwerk über die fritzbox geht dann haben die vielleicht irgendwelche empfänger auch auf der straße oder ich hab keine ahnung zumindest die neuen zähler sind nicht mehr so oldschool wo man das groß ablesen kann das ist ein zwischending zwischen einem smart zähler und einem oldschool zähler die zählen und können das übertragen was sie gezählt haben allerdings kann man das selbst noch sehr schlecht auslesen und das sagt natürlich
vielleicht lora ich weiß es nicht könnte sein so und das ist natürlich doof diesen zähler kann ich relativ easy mit einem line sensor auslesen den neuen dann nicht es sei denn der hat irgendeine led die ab und zu mal blinkt mit so und so viel kilowattstunden
so und das ist doof das heißt ich habe mich jetzt schon ich habe mir jetzt schon mal gedanken darüber gemacht was man machen kann wenn dieser zähler eben wegkommt und ich habe keinen zähler den ich gut auslesen kann zähler auslesen ist aktuell das einfachste zum stromverbrauch ermitteln weil ich verlasse mir einfach darauf dass der zähler das macht was er soll
moin megapan 2000 so und da habe ich dieses ding hier gefunden ich habe ja schon ein paar eigene zähler danach hin bauen ja das ist ja quasi sowas in der richtung ja ich habe ja schon einige shelly produkte bei mir im einsatz eigentlich hauptsächlich die da
war das andere was ich mir noch bestellt habe habe ich aber nie eingebaut genau davon habe ich ein paar die habe ich aber nicht eingebaut die sind einfach nur da aber davon habe ich einige also viele die meisten nicht viele aber die meisten die
meisten lichtschalter hier im ersten stock und in also in den räumen wo man wo leute öfters rein rausgehen die sind mittlerweile hiermit ausgestattet das heißt das ist ein wlan relay also sprich ich kann jetzt licht an und ausschalten übers wlan mit
meiner heim automatisierung und der vorteil von so einem relay ist der schalter geht nach wie vor noch kannst du den selber einbauen muss dafür elektriker kommen also wenn man wenn man gar nichts mit damit anfangen kann
mal wo ist das wo ist hier das diagramm dann ist besser mal letzten elektriker machen aber es geht das wichtigste ist nur man muss die sicherung raus machen strom ausmachen was braucht das ding an strom habe ich ehrlich gesagt nie
gemessen aber da ist ein esp 2866 drin also das dürfte so an der messung genau ich kann dran sein das ist nicht viel
so 100 milliampere oder so 3,3 volt 100 milliampere 150 milliampere beim wlan senden
moin moin max was geht hör gerade mit der twitch app auf audio all leader ins stream als podcast beim spazieren mega entspannt exzellent so muss was machen wusste gar nicht das was funktioniert ja so und
ich muss dazu sagen ich habe das auch nicht einfach aufgemacht und habe das daran gemacht ich habe das mit jemanden zusammen gemacht der elektro technisch etwas versierter ist wie ich und jetzt kriege ich das auch alleine hin aber ich würde es nicht empfehlen zu machen wenn man gar keine ahnung hat
und es ist auch es kann es kann nichts passieren großartig dabei sofern man den strom ausschaltet muss den strom ausschalten und wenn man sich nicht sicher ist sollte man halt nicht das ding da einfach ein wieder einbauen und denken passt schon sondern vielleicht mal gucke ob es auch funktioniert nachdem man den strom wieder angeschaltet hat nicht dass das ding irgendwie anfängt zu schmoren oder sonst was man muss da ein bisschen aufpassen dass man es richtig anschließt und man muss gucken je nachdem was man hier
bekommt wie die wie die trennung ist intern funktioniert das der sp 2866 mit 3,3 volt allerdings gibt es gibt es geräte da ist es so dass die das auf den pins dann 230 volt ist und so was da muss man genau gucken ist in dem fall nicht so weit ansonsten monka sterben ja aber ich würde ich würde nicht einfach dran gehen
ich würde höchstens dran gehen wenn man nachdem man sich das diagramm ganz genau angeguckt hat wie das funktioniert ja man schöneres diagramm gibt gibt ein paar bessere und wie gesagt strom aus auf keinen fall irgendwas mit strom anmachen
wer was mit nicht strom ausgeschaltet macht der ist lebensmüde und will sterben aber sowas ja wenn da irgendwie einer an seinem 5 volt raspberry rumbastelt wenn der strom an ist ist was anderes aber nicht da dran 11 monate dankeschön gw oz 13 kusch render excellent
ja also wo bin ich stehen geblieben davon habe ich ein paar und nun habe ich mir überlegt wenn ihr das wirklich machen und mein stromzähler ausbauen und ich da so einen hässlichen neuen stromzähler am start habe den ich nicht abgreifen kann
dann werde ich wahrscheinlich hiermit machen und zwar funktioniert das folgendermaßen das ist ein hat dieses menü gefahrt menü so das ist ungefähr gleicher baufaktor wie das andere auch nur dass man also zwei klemmen dran machen kann oder eine klemme
wo haben wir ein bild bild wiring diagrams ja da sieht man es ganz gut da kann man nämlich klemmen quasi im keller dann um die kabels machen also das hauptkabel und dann kann man das auch irgendwie messen das habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert die sache ist die ich finde eigentlich meine lösungen wie ich es jetzt aktuell habe ziemlich praktisch aber mir wird wahrscheinlich nichts anderes übrig bleiben
es sei denn der neue laser lässt leser lässt sich auch über in der led die blink auslesen oder so dann wäre ok aber hat der zähler keine zahlen man die man per open cv auslesen könnte ehrlich gesagt keine ahnung ich könnte mir vorstellen doch der hat noch eine zahl aber foto machen bilderkennung und das alles quasi im im im mehr oder weniger dunklen oder kurz ist nicht schön besser besser sowas oder besser noch besser so wie ich es jetzt auch hat mit so einem sensor hier oben drüber
ja zumindest wollte ich mir da schon mal zwei drei bestellen die haben wieder die übliche hardware drinne man kann sie verwenden mit der offiziellen ab dem offiziellen web interface man kann aber auch custom flaschen
ja wieder fit geht so 90 prozent genau da wollte ich mir welche bestellen wenn ich jetzt sehen würde wo man die bestellen kann products schelle em ausgibt schelle em und schelle 3 3 em
wo ist denn da der unterschied was ist der unterschied zwischen dem em und 3em sind da wahrscheinlich mehrere mehrere anschlüsse
oh
was ist da jetzt der unterschied außer dass der fancier aussieht kann ich da mehrere mehrere sachen anschließen
ich habe halt von elektronik relativ wenig ahnung das heißt mir sagt das alles nichts wenn ich das lese was kostet denn der kram shop shop
ja ich finde der ist übelst hässlich ich finde der ist viel besser 82 dann dire ich aber eher zu dem hier
da muss ich mich auf jeden fall noch mal schlau machen und ich hoffe ich brauche es nicht aber wie gesagt wenn die meinen zähler demnächst ausbauen wenn die das wirklich ernst meinen dann wäre das ziemlich das sack
pass auf die schiene im kassau das natürlich gut ah guck mal gibt es aber das könnten sie aber von hinten machen dass man wirklich sieht ob er auf die wenn er nämlich auf die schiene passt wäre sehr praktisch
keine ahnung was für ein zähler habe ich so ein ding so was unterm hausanschluss dran ist ich habe keine ahnung was das ist wenn er auf die schiene passt natürlich doppelt praktisch
ja das wäre praktisch da kann ich nämlich unten direkt reinklemmen wäre dann wahrlich exzellent gut dann wird das ding schon mal bestellt weil das ganz schön teuer ist
gibt es nicht gibt es nicht irgendwelche sachen über den die man esp 32 machen kann oder so ist aber glaube ich drei phasen ok was was heißt das was heißt das wie gesagt ich kenne mich mit elektronik kram nicht wirklich aus
no limit x o drei monate dankeschön exzellent subscription dankeschön für den sup ok du brauchst drei was heißt das denn der chat wieder ich verstehe nichts
das ist die frage liegt am chat oder an mir muss am chat liegen ja mag sein ich habe davon keine ahnung
so was dürfte mich nicht fragen keine ahnung keine ahnung ok also aber ich brauche den da anscheinend brauche ich den da ok was auch immer ich muss mir das auf jeden fall nochmal in ruhe angucken bevor ich da was bestell
gut dann hätten wir das thema ja schon mal abgehakt shelly em als nächstes habe ich letztens hier ein video gesehen das fand ich sehr nice und zwar ein m2 m2 adapter von raspberry pi genau das war das das ding
genau das teile das fand ich von der konstruktion her eigentlich ganz nice weil man das eben direkt mit so einer brücke per usb dran machen kann das ist quasi m2 mount für unsere paye finde ich das finde ich eigentlich nicht schlecht klar natürlich man kann einfach nur
Man kann einfach nur USB-Stick dran machen, dann steht es da hinten ein bisschen rüber raus.
Oder man kann einfach nur USB-Adapter auf SSD machen, geht auch und die SSD unten drunter stellen, ist auch nicht viel größer.
Aber den Adapter finde ich cool, da wollte ich mal gucken, was das Ding kostet.
Und ob es den auch in Deutschland gibt.
Ja, die USB-Anbindung vom Raspberry Pi kannst du eh knicken.
Pi 4? Wahrscheinlich gibt es das in Deutschland nicht.
Könnte ich mir vorstellen.
Ach doch, guck mal.
Geht sogar in doll.
Ist aber ganz schön teuer.
30 Euro für so ein Kackbord, was kostet...
Das ist viel zu teuer, das sehe ich nicht ein.
Bei AliExpress gibt es sowas bestimmt.
Gucken wir mal, bei AliExpress gibt es sowas für 3,50.
So, was macht der Video?
Ja gut, so kleine Kackdinger habe ich selbst.
Also 30 Euro finde ich ein bisschen teuer.
Warum soll ich 30 Euro ausgeben für ein Board, was im Endeffekt nichts anderes macht als unter dem Raspberry hängen und...
Was ist denn das für ein hässliches Ding?
Wenn ich da so ein ekliches Gehäuse drum herum mache, dann lohnt sich das mit der M2 unten drunter doch gar nicht.
Ok, wisst ihr was, ich bleibe einfach bei meinem USB auf SATA und gut ist.
Aktuell habe ich einen USB auf SATA und ganz ehrlich, die SATA SSD ist nur minimal größer als der Raspberry Pi.
Das lohnt sich überhaupt nicht.
Hätte das jetzt 7 Euro gekostet, dann hätte ich es mir jetzt überlegt.
Aber wozu? Das ist komplett sinnlos.
Die SSD ist ungefähr genauso groß hier.
Wenn ich jetzt so ein Board drunter mache oder eine SSD darunter mache, ist doch kein Ding.
Im Zweifelsfall ist es die SSD zwar nicht so schön am Raspberry Pi dran, aber ich kann es einfach dran kleben, wenn es sein muss.
Wenn ich ganz hardcore drauf bin und den Kram nicht wieder verwenden will, mache ich mit Heißkleber fest.
Dann wird einfach die SSD an den Raspberry Pi geheißklebert und gut ist.
Oh, ich brauche Heißkleber, fällt mir gerade ein.
Ich habe das letzte Mal schon geguckt, aber ich habe keine bestellt.
Ich brauche noch Heißkleber-Sticks, solche Dinger hier.
Ich weiß aber nicht, was meine für einen Durchmesser hat.
Kleber.
Was ist das? 11 Millimeter, ok.
11 Millimeter.
Brauche Sticks.
Ja.
Klebe. Ultra Power.
Wisst ihr, was ich nicht ganz kapiert habe?
Neradon, 11, 13 Monate.
Excellent Subscription, danke schön.
Huge.
Wisst ihr, was ich noch nicht so ganz kapiert habe?
Was ist...
Was ist die Daseinsberechtigung von Heißkleber?
Ich meine, es klebt gut, aber wisst ihr, wie ich das meine?
Gibt es irgendeinen Grund, warum Heißkleber besser klebt als kalter Kleber?
Weil, weil, wenn ich das Gleiche in Kalt holen könnte,
und ich habe schon Videos gesehen, da haben Leute so einen Zwei-Komponenten-Kleber genommen,
zusammen gemischt, und das Ding war, und das Ding war
so extrem fest, da konnte ein halbes Auto dran hängen.
Ich glaube, das Geile ist die Wiederverwendbarkeit, nicht die Klebekraft.
Hä? Wie Wiederverwendbarkeit?
Da kannst du doch nichts... Was meinst du mit Wiederver...
Wenn das Stick weg ist, ist es weg?
Ich meine, der Kram ist wirklich brutal fest, ja?
Also, ich erkenne auch nicht, was man da drin wiederverwenden kann.
Günstig, oder vielleicht ist es einfach billiger.
Vielleicht ist es am Preis gemessen fester oder so, weil ansonsten verstehe ich den Sinn nicht.
Es gibt ja auch kalten Kleber, der gut fließt.
Doch, ich habe, doch, doch, ich habe einen Vorteil von Heißkleber.
Fällt mir gerade ein, und das ist eigentlich mit das Beste.
Es geht zackig. Also, du machst Heißkleber drauf.
Fünf Sekunden später ist es fest.
Also, du machst das drauf, drückst dran, warte fünf Sekunden, ist fest.
Das ist natürlich, das ist echt ein Vorteil.
Ich glaube, das hast du bei normalem Kleberzeug nicht.
Gut, davon brauche ich auf jeden Fall wieder welche.
Und du kannst den Kleber lösen, während du ihn erwärmst.
Ja, okay, okay.
Hab ich doch nie ausprobiert, geht das echt?
Bei Wikipedia gibt es eine Pro-Contra-Liste.
Ernsthaft?
Kann übrigens nicht schreiben.
Wo? Ah.
Niedriger Materialpreis, schnelle Farbe, das stimmt.
Das ist tatsächlich auch der erste Vorteil, der mir eben eingefallen ist.
Das geht sau schnell.
Du sprichst das raus, drückst kurz dran und es ist fest.
Man kann es wieder entfernen.
Okay.
Ich habe damit die Kamera an die Wand geklebt.
Ich habe eine Kamera fürs Hoftor.
Und die ist mit Heißkleber, nicht an der Wand.
An dem Winkel zwischen Wand und Fensterbrett ist die Kamera fürs Hoftor.
Sie habe ich einfach heiß geklebert.
Einfach eine halbe Ladung Heißkleber hin, das Ding reingedrückt und bombenfest.
Es hat schon gestürmt, geregnet, gesonst war.
Das hat das Ding überhaupt nicht interessiert.
Hiprons, drei Monate, Dankeschön.
Für den Sub.
Bei dem warmen Wetter, die Dinger schmelzen bei 200 Grad oder so.
Aber so warm ist es ja draußen nicht.
Ich weiß nicht, bei wie viel Temperatur, Grad, bei wie viel Schmelzen die.
Steht nicht dabei.
Ich lerne gerade meinen C++-Compiler hassen, schreibt Phipps2.
Die Königsdisziplin ist natürlich nicht nur den C++-Compiler hassen, sondern C++ an sich hassen.
Das ist viel besser.
240 Grad, okay.
Davon brauche ich auf jeden Fall auch noch einen.
Jetzt bin ich am Überlegen.
Chat, ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich kaufen soll.
Ich brauche es nicht oft, aber ich habe mir gedacht, das ist so was.
Ich habe ja gerade erst Geburtstag gehabt.
Das ist so was, wo ich schon lange Zeit mit Liebäugle.
Aber ich es eigentlich zu selten brauche, um es zu rechtfertigen, es zu kaufen.
Und zwar das hier.
Wie heißt das?
Maul, nicht Maul, Maul.
Ja, das da wahrscheinlich.
So was hier, aber immer ohne die Nummer hinten dran.
So, ich brauche es zu selten.
Aber ich hätte schon immer gerne eins gehabt.
Ich habe ja recht viel von Vera.
Und das ist so was.
Ich hätte es einfach gerne, ja.
Aber ich brauche es halt eigentlich nicht.
Ich brauche so ein Ding vielleicht einmal im halben Jahr oder so.
Und was ist das Tolle an denen?
Ich zeige dir mal, falls sie ein Video dazu haben, zeige ich dir das mal.
Ich versuche es mal aus dem Kopf.
Ich weiß, es hört sich jetzt wieder wie ein Werbevideo an.
Warum ich mir die Dinger kaufen wollte, was an denen richtig cool ist.
Erstens, die haben so eine Haltefunktion.
Also sprich, man sieht man doch hier bestimmt irgendwo.
Ja, genau.
Sprich, man kann die Sachen hier rein machen und die rutschen nicht raus.
Das ist aber glaube ich auch falsch rum.
Also man kann quasi die Schraube rein machen und die Schraube hält,
selbst wenn ich den Schlüssel ausstrecke.
Das ist cool.
Und dazu kommt, das haben die aber alle, auch die billigeren,
dazu kommt, dass die eine Ratschefunktion haben.
Das heißt, ich kann damit Sachen festdrehen.
Gucken wir mal, ob das im Video zu sehen ist.
Ja, guckt, da ist so eine...
Nein, Moment.
Hier sieht man es noch nicht, hier sieht man es noch nicht, hier sieht man es noch nicht.
Hier sieht man es noch nicht, das ist einfach so, wie es normal funktioniert.
Genau, guckt, das ist nämlich richtig nice, das hält.
Habt ihr es gesehen?
Die Schraube hält, ohne dass du es festhalten musst.
Also sprich, du kannst die Schraube rein machen
und dann kannst du den Schlüssel ausstrengen mit der Schraube.
Das ist eigentlich übelst nice.
So, aber das beste Feature ist, das beste Feature kommt glaube ich noch irgendwann.
Ja, genau, man rutscht nicht mehr drüber.
Ja, okay, ich weiß nicht.
Okay, der Typ ist ultra low brain, aber jetzt wird der Vera-Schlüssel alles gut.
2-Hedge, 3-Hedge, oi, oi mate, oi.
Aber das beste Feature kommt gleich noch, was auch nur die teureren können.
Ja, so ist gut.
Oh Gott, ist ja gut.
Der Typ muss sich auch doof vorkommen, oder?
Der tut ja fast so, als kriegst du mit anderen Schraubschlüsseln nichts fest.
Okay, ganz so schlimm ist es jetzt auch nicht, dass nur Vera-Schlüssel die Sachen festschrauben.
Minus 1-Hedge ist das.
Aber das beste Feature kommt jetzt noch, ich hoffe das zeigen die.
Ja, ja, bla, bla, bla.
Wir zeigen die nicht.
Ah doch, guck mal, Leute.
Bestes Feature.
Du kannst damit quasi, ohne dass du die Schraube rausmachen musst, wie mit so einer Knarre, Ratsche,
kannst du quasi die Schrauben festmachen, ohne dass du absetzen musst.
Ich kenne keine anderen Schlüssel, die dieses Feature haben, außer die von Vera.
Und das finde ich cool.
Das hat was.
Und das in Kombination mit dieser Auflage für die Schrauben und dieses Ding, das ist was,
das wollte ich mir schon lange mal holen.
Wie gesagt, wenn es hochkommt einmal im Monat, wo ich sowas brauche, aber nice to have.
Du schraubst dein Auto rum und das ist Gold wert.
Kann ich mir vorstellen, ja.
170 ist übertrieben.
Ja, dafür braucht man eigentlich auch nichts anderes.
Wobei ich das ja für ein vorgeschobenes Argument halte.
Ich bringe das selber gerne immer, wenn ich unnötig viel Geld für Werkzeuge ausgebe,
so nach dem Motto, ja, dann kaufst du halt einmal und brauchst da nie wieder was kaufen.
Es ist Schwachsinn.
Leute, die gerne gutes Werkzeug kaufen und die halt auch Spaß daran haben, die kaufen
sich dann auch eventuell in 5, 6 Jahren eine neuere Variante davon, obwohl sie es schon
haben und obwohl es nicht mal ansatzweise kaputt ist.
Genau, das kaufst du dir nur einmal im Leben, was aber nicht stimmt.
Wenn man ehrlich ist, stimmt das nicht.
Gerade Leute, die Spaß an gutem Werkzeug haben und denen das gefällt und da auch gucken,
was es Neues gibt, kann es durchaus sein, dass sie sich in einigen Jahren dann die neuere
Variante kaufen, weil da irgendwas cooles Neues dran ist und obwohl die Alte nicht kaputt ist.
Dankeschön, Credo.
Also, das wollte ich mir bestellen.
Und so wie ich das jetzt aus dem Chat lese, hat das wohl auch die einen oder anderen Fans
von dem Chat.
Ja, aber ist auf jeden Fall nice und bei dem Set ist auch so ziemlich alles dabei in der
Größe, was man braucht.
Wo ich Bavera noch nicht mit warm geworden bin, ist dieses Farbquartier-System.
Von der Logik her, von der Logik her ist es ja so, dass die gleiche Größe Bavera immer
die gleiche Farbe hat.
Also sprich, wenn ich jetzt irgendwie Bits aufsetze, suche oder so in dieser Größe,
dann hätte das auch hier Gelb oder so.
Oder Schraubendreher oder was auch immer.
So war die Theorie, aber ich benutze das nie.
Die Farbkodierung geht mir sonst wo vorbei.
Was haltet ihr vom TS-100-Lötkolben?
Das habe ich mir vor einer Weile mal angeguckt, das Ding.
Das war dieser Lötkolben, mit dem man irgendwie mit Custom-Firmware flashen konnte.
Ganz ehrlich, nix.
Ich habe es mir damals auch angeguckt, so cool das ist, dass es einen Lötkolben gibt
mit Custom-Firmware.
Es gibt jetzt auch einen TS-80, aber ich sehe den Grund dafür nicht.
Ganz ehrlich, die Daseinsberechtigung für solche Gadget-Lötkolben erschließt sich
mir nicht.
Ein Lötkolben braucht bei mir eigentlich keine großartige Intelligenz.
Das reicht, wenn die Station, das hat auch was Temperaturregelung angeht.
Ein Lötkolben sollte eine Sache machen, der sollte ein möglichst flexibles Kabel
haben, so klein wie möglich sein und Spitzen haben, die man austauschen kann
und angenehm in der Hand liegen.
Aber ansonsten sollte ein Lötkolben so dumm wie möglich sein.
Ich habe es im letzten Einkaufsstream schon mal gezeigt.
Seitdem ich mir das Ding als Lötstation gekauft habe, muss ich echt sagen, das war
eine der besten Investitionen seit langem.
Das hat es richtig gelohnt, die Kombination hier.
Mir hat das Löten noch nie mehr Spaß gemacht als damit.
Vor allem, wenn man sich die Lötkolben anguckt, ist das coole daran.
Ich weiß, es ist heute die übelste Werbeveranstaltung.
Du hast ein super flexibles Kabel, was im Vergleich zu diesen Lidl-Lötkolben da,
wer so ein Ding schon mal in der Hand gehabt hat, dem wird es grausen kommen.
Die Parkseite-Dinger gehen ja meistens noch irgendwo halbwegs.
Aber so etwas Billiges hier, das ist der Teufel.
Das ist der absolute Teufel, diese billige Lötkolben hier.
Das ist eine komplett andere Geschichte.
Das ist so groß, ich weiß nicht, ob du ihm eine Hand daneben legst.
Das Ding ist so dick wie ein Finger, so dick wie ein Daumen ungefähr,
ein bisschen dicker als ein Daumen.
Ungefähr so lang wie eine Hand und hat ein ziemlich flexibles Kabel.
Man kann die Spitzen tauschen.
Top, das ist wirklich die beste Variante.
Seitdem ich das Ding habe, habe ich überhaupt keinen Bedarf mehr,
nach irgendwelchen anderen Geschichten, was Lötkolben angeht, zu gucken.
Nichtsdestotrotz, ich habe mir mal einen billigen USB-Lötkolben gekauft.
Der ist tatsächlich gar nicht so schlecht.
Der ist im Vergleich zu der Ersagerin übelster Müll, aber wofür ich...
Nein, nicht so ein Ding.
Das Teil hatte ich mir mal gekauft, weil ich wissen wollte,
ob das überhaupt funktioniert.
Ich wollte einfach nur wissen, ob das funktioniert.
Das war der einzige Grund, warum ich mir das gekauft habe.
Ja, es funktioniert, aber nicht gut.
Aber besser als ich gedacht habe.
Es funktioniert eigentlich ganz brauchbar.
Das Einzige, wozu ich das jetzt verwende, ist,
wenn ich mal wirklich irgendwo schnell was dran machen muss.
Das ist der einzige, wenn ich keinen Bock habe,
die Silikonunterlage rauszuholen dafür.
Also sprich, wenn ich wirklich mal kurz was dran machen muss
oder schnell was abmachen muss oder irgendwas aus...
Das ist der einzige Grund, wenn ich den verwende,
für ernsthaftes Rumgelöte, was auch längerfristig im Bestand bleibt.
Gar kein Fall.
Man kann den sogar aus einer Powerbank betreiben.
Dass es sowas gibt, hat mich damals nur gewundert.
Und dass er funktioniert, hat mich noch mehr gewundert.
Jolly, Joka, drei Monate.
Excellent Subscription, Dankeschön.
Ich kann ihn auch als Dart-Pfeil nehmen.
So spitz, wie der hier aussieht, ist der gar nicht.
Ich habe mal reingegriffen aus Versehen.
Also schon recht spitz, aber nicht so, wie es hier ausschaut.
Naja, so viel zum USB-Thema.
USB-Lotkolben.
Ja, und ich glaube, ich kaufe mir den hier.
Also nicht USB-Lotkolben.
Ich glaube, ich kaufe mir jetzt den Satz.
Oh, guck mal, es gibt noch.
Warum ist das noch teurer?
Warum kostet das?
Ah, weil die mit Absatz sind, oder wie ist das?
Warum?
Oh.
Ah, die sind angewinkelt, oder wie, oder was?
What?
Ach, da kannst du vor und zurück umstellen.
Da kannst du vor...
Oh, das ist ja nochmal eine Nummer geiler.
Also man muss sagen, bei Vera, die haben das schon drauf.
Die können, die schaffen das, vier verschiedene Varianten rauszubringen davon.
Und obwohl es schon saumäßig teuer ist, überlegst du, ob du nicht doch die teurere Variante...
Aber ich ganz ehrlich, das ist...
Vom Aufbacher ist mir das eigentlich lieber.
Das angewinkelt, braucht man das echt?
Ich stelle mir das eher hinderlich vor, wenn das angewinkelt ist.
Nein, 270 Euro!
Das ist schon schweileteuer.
Zum Glück ist es metrisch, dass keiner auf die Idee kommt, dass das irgendwelche Freedom-Units sind.
Was dann ankommt, mit Inches oder so?
Nee, ich glaube das hier.
160 ist schon teuer, aber 270 ist nochmal eine ganze Nummer krasser.
Hattest du nicht vom Killer Chris damals so ein Metall gefräst?
Ja, das habe ich noch, das hängt hier.
Besser gesagt, steht auf dem Schrank.
Noble geht die Welt zu Grunde, aber das ist mir zu teuer.
Also der für 270, das ist mir zu teuer, nee.
Nee, nee.
Dann gibt es die noch in allen möglichen Größenvarianten.
Dann gibt es hier noch Einzel.
Das hört ja gar nicht mehr auf.
Und hier gibt es irgendeinen Nachbau von Gear Ranch.
Jetzt klemmt die Kreditkarte, ich bezahle das doch eh nicht per Kreditkarte.
Das geht direkt abgebucht vom Konto bei Amazon.
270 Euro für ein paar Schlüssel, nee, das muss echt nicht sein.
Gut, so viel dazu, aber ich glaube den bestelle ich mir.
Das lacht mich irgendwie an, dieses Set hier.
Kommt das in der Tasche oder kommt das echt nur so?
Ich meine, eine Tasche sollte da schon drinnen sein.
Ich meine, ich verstehe, warum das sowas ist.
Das ist, wenn man einen Werkzeugkasten hat, dass man das gut reinstellen kann.
Aber das dürfte schon in der Tasche kommen, oder?
Weil ich meine, eine Tasche ist, vielleicht ist die Tasche bei 170 Euro nicht mehr drin.
Nee, das kann man nicht rollen.
Ich glaube nicht, dass man die rollen kann.
Oder?
Das sieht eher aus wie ein recht fester Einsatz für einen Werkzeugkasten.
Kann man das rollen?
Ah, sorry, in robuster Tasche, okay, alles klar.
Ja, ich wollte gerade sagen, selbst AliExpress, selbst AliExpress hat sowas.
Übrigens, ich kann es nicht selbst, ich kann es nicht selbst, weil ich es hier gerade sehe.
Ich kann es nicht selbst empfehlen, weil ich habe nichts von diesem Hersteller.
Ich habe jetzt allerdings von, also ich habe erstens in sehr vielen Foren das schon gelesen.
Ich habe auf der Arbeitenkollege, da ist übelster Proxxon-Fan.
Und ich habe jetzt an vielen Stellen schon gehört, auch in Videos, wo es um Werkzeuge geht,
dass wenn man nicht total viel Kohle ausgeben möchte, aber trotzdem gutes Werkzeug haben will,
ist Proxxon nicht verkehrt.
Wenn man gescheite Sachen haben will, die nicht ultra teuer sind, sollen die wohl wirklich nicht...
Die sehen auch so oldschool aus, das sieht auch so aus mit dieser Metallbox,
mit dieser grünen Metallbox, könnte auch so aussehen wie, ähm, wie von meinem Opa noch irgendwo, ne?
Also, die sollen auch ganz gut sein.
Gut, aber hier genug Einkauf, was ist das denn hier?
Ein Werkzeug-XL-Container.
Ach, das ist eher was, wo man damit im Außendienst rumlaufen kann.
What the fuck, Werra? Ihr wollt 223 für eine Stofftasche? Ernsthaft?
Also, man kann es ja auch übertreiben.
Da ist nichts dabei. Da ist einfach nur Platz.
Für den Preis kriegste ja, kann ich in Louis Vuitton-Store gehen und...
Louis Vuitton-Straße, Louis Vuitton-Store, zahl die Kollektion barf, fick auf Sponsor.
Ist ein Container, ok, ja ok, es ist ein Container, der aussieht wie eine Tasche.
Gut, nächstes Ding, also abhaken erstmal, abhaken.
Abhaken.
Investierst du in Aktien, aber nein, in Werra-Produkte.
Wenn das möglich wäre, dass man damit auch Geld verdient, würde ich sofort machen.
Für Cuts-FPS, zeig mal her.
Ach, sowas haben wir schon, sowas mag die nicht.
Ne, sowas interessiert die nicht.
Meine Cuts ist äußerst resistent, was Spielzeug angeht.
Ich hab mir letztens so einen Ball hier gekauft.
Automatischer Ball, irgendwas sowas hier in der Richtung.
Sowas in der Richtung ungefähr, habe ich mir letztens gekauft.
Und ich dachte mir, die Cuts findet das ganz toll.
Das machst du da an, das machst du da an und dann rollt das random über den Boden und leuchtet rot.
Ah, meine Cuts hat Angst davor.
Die haut ab, da verfolgt der Ball die Cuts und nicht die Cuts den Ball.
Die hat Angst vor dem Ball.
Das einzige, wo das geht ist, wenn ich den Ball im Katzentunnel verstecke und der Ball dann quasi nur noch rot da drin leuchtet,
dann findet es entspannend, aber ansonsten hat die Angst davor.
Gibt es eine Möglichkeit, den PC per Smart Home zu starten?
Klar, zig, hunderte Varianten sind da denkbar.
Von Wake on LAN bis eine Steckdose, die du einschaltest, alle möglichen Sachen.
Da gibt es tausende Variante, wie du deinen PC über Smart Home starten kannst.
Moment, warum habe ich überhaupt Amazon auf? Ich will kein Echo kaufen.
Sowas ist echt das letzte, was ich mir in den Raum stellen würde.
Das ist quasi Spyware in Hardware Form.
Die Katze riecht aus China Plastik.
Da wird aber lange nach China Plastik riechen.
So, nächstes, also das hatten wir jetzt.
Ja, jetzt müssen wir mal wieder in den Pimeroni Store gehen und mal den Dark Reader ausmachen.
Oh, guck mal, stimmt, es gibt doch jetzt eine neue Raspberry Pi Cam.
Die gibt es doch noch gar nicht so lange, die gibt es erst 2-3 Monate oder so.
Aber eigentlich komplett useless für meinen Anwendungszweck, viel zu groß.
Viel zu groß und irgendwie ohne Objektiv kann das sein. Ne, brauch ich nicht.
Was kostet sie? 50 Dollar, das ist doch Müll.
Boah, 100, Alter, 100 Pfund.
100 Pfund, guck mal, ich müsste 50 Euro für die Cam, für den Sensor ausgeben und 50 Pfund.
100 Pfund für die...
Ne, also mal ganz einfach abgesehen, dass ich das eh nicht brauche, weil die Kamera viel zu groß ist für den Anwendungszweck, wo ich die Pi Cam am Start habe.
Ne, aber was ich hier gucken wollte ist, ob die noch Fire Beetle ESP32 haben, weil das die letzte Mal haben sie noch.
Die einzigen waren in Europa, die lieferbar waren und die erschwinglich waren.
Da bräuchte ich nämlich noch 2 Stück für. Das ist das beste Low Power ESP32 Board, was es gibt.
Also eines der wenigen Low Power ESP32 Boards.
Low Power heißt in dem Fall, dass wenn du den in Deep Sleep schickst, dass der alles abschaltet, auch USB, Spannungswandler und so.
Der verbraucht nur noch 10 Mikroamper im Standby.
Das heißt, den kannst du wirklich, wenn du dir jetzt nicht alle 30 Sekunden aufwächst, kannst du den sogar über ein Jahr an der Batterie lassen.
Also so eine 1200 mAh Batterie.
Und das Ding, wenn du das am Tag 4-5 Mal aufwächst, hält das vielleicht 2 Jahre oder so an der Batterie.
Und davon wollte ich mir noch 2 Stück bestellen, weil ich habe wieder Big Brain gemacht.
Ich habe nämlich aufgeräumt, den einen habe ich kaputt gemacht.
Beim Aufräumen, weil ich auf die, auf die, na hier, wartet mal, was habe ich denn hier?
Weil ich hier auf die Plastikverpackung draufgetreten bin, da war noch was drin.
Normalerweise gehen die Dinger nicht kaputt, wenn du da drauf trittst.
Normalerweise gehen die Dinger nicht kaputt, aber wenn halt was drunter liegt, gehen sie kaputt.
Also du kannst dich fast auf die Dinger drauf stellen und es passiert nichts, solange du es nicht mit Schuhen irgendwie machst.
Aber wenn halt was drunter steht und du trittst drauf, ist es kaputt.
Das war halt Fail.
Und den anderen, den habe ich schon vor einer Weile kaputt gemacht.
Ich vermute mal, weil ich die Batterie irgendwie an einen falschen Pin angeschlossen habe.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich habe jetzt nur noch einen und den brauche ich ja noch für mein, ich brauche ja zwei.
Ich brauche ja für meinen Friedhof und für mein Briefkastenprojekt noch was.
Trittst du da öfters drauf? Ja, passiert schon ab und zu mal, dass ich auf irgendwelche Elektronikteile drauf trete.
Bei den meisten passiert nichts.
Am schmerzhaften war es mal auf einem, wo ich einen Jumperwire in der Ferse hatte danach.
Das habe ich auf einmal nur noch gehört, dass es gemacht hat.
Das kann man gar nicht nachmachen.
Das war so ein komisches Geräusch.
So hat es an der Ferse gemacht.
So richtig, weil an der Ferse, an der Ferse vom Fuß, da ist die Haut ja relativ dick.
Und ich rede von solchen Kabeln hier.
So welche waren das, genau so welche.
Und da lag halt irgendwie ein Kabel auf der Erd, hier unten am Schreibtisch.
Und ich habe die Ferse, ich habe den Teppich, ich habe mich vorgeschoben mit dem Stuhl nach vorne.
Und habe dann halt an der Ferse zurückgefahren über den Teppich.
Und dann hat es dann auf einmal an der Ferse richtig laut gemacht.
Und das war halt die Haut, die quasi aufgeplatzt ist an der Ferse.
Wo sich das Kabel rein gebohrt hat.
Und es hat erst nicht wehgetan.
Es hat so 5 Sekunden gedauert oder so, aber dann hat es wehgetan.
Und es hat auch ein paar Tage wehgetan, weil es doch schon ein recht großes Loch macht, wenn du so ein Ding in der Ferse stecken kannst.
Das war doch etwas Pains Champ.
Aber der Rest ist weder mir noch den Teilen.
Weißt du was passiert, wenn ich draufgetreten habe?
Jungs ist es eine gute Idee einen Hyper-V Cluster mit zwei Nux zu bauen für zu Hause.
Kommt darauf an, ob du das zu Studienzwecken machen möchtest.
Oder ob du das wirklich betreiben willst.
Das war so die grundsätzliche Sache.
Wenn du es wirklich betreiben willst, ist die erste Frage, die ich mir stellen würde.
Also was du durch Cluster Geschichten gewinnst.
Zum Üben aber auch ein NAS Software.
Also gerade ein NAS ist Vmware Cluster technisch nicht ohne.
Weil du brauchst ja dann den Storage theoretisch an allen Standorten.
Oder du brauchst noch einen extra NAS dazwischen, äh nicht NAS.
Einen extra SAN dazwischen, was dann für dich die HA vom Storage macht, was du daheim wahrscheinlich nicht hast.
Aber wenn du natürlich einfach nur zwei Nux haben willst und Raspberry Pi Cluster ohne HA machen willst,
dann kannst du einfach einen Nux nehmen.
Dann kannst du nämlich auf den zweiten brauchst du nicht.
Wozu?
Ansonsten, wenn es kompakt sein muss, kannst du einen Nux nehmen.
Wenn du nicht großartige Anforderungen hast an die Hardware, geht es aber auch noch billiger und besser erweiterbar.
Weil das Problem am Nux ist, dass du keinen PCI Express hast.
Und ich weiß nicht, wie wählerisch Vmware mittlerweile mit Storage ist und solchen Sachen.
Ich hab ewig kein Vmware, also kein ESX mehr installiert.
Ich weiß nur, dass früher ESX sehr wählerisch war, was Storage und Netzwerk Hardware anbelangt.
Also, dass man extra gucken musste, was man einbaut, dass es das erkennt.
Aber wahrscheinlich ist das mittlerweile besser.
Hast du beruflich Berührungspunkte mit Machine Learning?
Ja, so ganz am Rande.
Nee, eigentlich nicht. Ganz am Rande nur.
Was wir jetzt haben auf der Arbeit ist, bezüglich Machine Learning.
Hab ich auch letztens gestaunt.
Ich hab letztens Kisten entdeckt.
Ich stolpe öfters mal über irgendwelche Server, wo man sich fragt, wie kommen die denn da her?
Ach, er macht Hyper-V, hab ich mich verlesen.
Ich hab gedacht, er macht ESX.
Okay, zu Hyper-V kann ich noch weniger sagen. Keine Ahnung.
Hyper-V gar kein Plassen-Schimmer.
Hyper-V hab ich noch nie gemacht.
Zumindest, ich bin letztens über ein paar Kisten von uns gestolpert,
die irgendwas mit Elastic Search KI oder so hießen.
Und dann bin ich zu unserem Elastic Search-Mann und hab gefragt, sag mal,
was machen wir denn da mit AI und Elastic Search?
Und dann hat er mir erzählt, wir haben jetzt einen Elastic Search Machine Learning Cluster,
der für uns quasi Big Brain Machine Learning,
Lock aufkommt, analysiert und quasi lernt, wann Locks kritisch sind und wann nicht.
Jetzt muss ich mal wieder Boomer-Modus einschalten.
Früher wusste man noch ungefähr, was seine Dienste loggen
und man konnte sich drei, vier Regex zurechtlegen,
die dann gematcht haben und dann wurde man auch alarmiert.
Aber mittlerweile muss das Locksystem per Machine Learning lernen,
welche Locks kritisch sind und wann die Dienste Probleme haben und welche nicht.
Kein Schimmer, was das für ein Ding wieder ist.
Aber mittlerweile, wir machen auch Machine Learning.
Ja, wir sind eh die Geilsten überhaupt, was das angeht.
Den Sinn hab ich auch nicht ganz verstanden.
Also nein, ich hab mit Machine Learning nichts zu tun.
Aber ja, wir haben auch irgendwas Machine Learning-mäßiges bei uns auf der Arbeit im Einsatz.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, was es tut und was es macht.
H.S.Yohi schreibt, so was Ähnliches macht er auch gerade als Bachelorarbeit
mit Prometheus für ein Kubernetes-Klasse.
Allerdings nur erstmal regelbasiert ohne AI.
Ja, regelbasiert ist ja die klassische Geschichte.
Wie gesagt, früher wusste es da auch ungefähr, was eine schlechte Meldung im Lock ist.
Hat dann ein Regex gebaut und dann hat er die gesagt,
oh, Locks-Fehler aufgetreten über 50 oder sonst was, Monitoring Alert.
Habt ihr das in der Cloud oder On-Premise?
Wir haben das bei uns laufen, nicht in der Cloud.
Das haben wir nicht in der Cloud.
Hätten wir das nämlich in der Cloud stehen,
hätt ich das gar nicht bei uns in der Hostliste irgendwo gefunden.
Im Endeffekt lernt die AI, ich hab keine Ahnung, was die AI macht.
Also ich hab eher das Gefühl, das ist so ein Ding, was die im Angebot haben,
damit sie auch was Machine Learning verkaufen können,
weil Machine Learning gerade angesagt ist, keine Ahnung.
Die einzige Machine Learning Sache, die ich,
oder noch nicht mal wirklich Machine Learning im eigentlichen Sinne,
die einzige Sache ein bisschen in dieser Richtung, die ich mal gemacht habe,
haben wir auch zusammen im Stream gemacht und zwar,
das war die Bewegungserkennung mit OpenCV.
Worum geht es gerade?
Elasticsearch, Elasticsearch Machine Learning.
Wir haben noch mal im Stream mit OpenCV versucht,
Bewegung in einem Bild zu erkennen.
Genau, zum Beispiel hier drin.
Da haben wir doch versucht, Bewegung zu erkennen in einem Videostream.
Und das hat erstaunlich gut funktioniert.
Ah yes, exquisite move, exquisite move.
Das würde ich auch so machen, ah yes.
Und das hat gut funktioniert.
Ist nicht wirklich Machine Learning, aber zumindest noch das,
was am nächsten da dran ist, was ich bisher gemacht habe.
So, das hatten wir jetzt.
So, jetzt gibt es jetzt noch irgendwas Sinnvolles,
was ich ja auch kaufen will.
Genau, so ein Fire Beetle.
Warum habe ich das jetzt zugemacht?
Kacknup.
Das kostet ja 18 Dollar vor 18 Pfund.
Was sind denn 18 Pfund in Euro?
Da haben wir doch die Überwachungsvideos angeguckt, genau.
Ja.
So sieht es aus.
21 Euro.
Und wie sieht es mit Versand aus?
Ok, sagen wir mal 5 Stück.
Zack.
I agree.
Was kostet eine Versand?
Versand nach.
Ich will einfach nur wissen, was der Versand kostet.
Ok, keine Ahnung.
Max, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla.
Zeil 1 in Frankfurt.
By the way, das habe ich...
Genau das da habe ich letztens selbst programmiert.
Mit...
Für unsere Routenberechnungsgeschichte da,
was ich euch schon ein paar Mal erzählt habe.
Genau sowas.
Und das ist komplizierter, als es auf den ersten Blick aussieht.
Dass man hier zum Beispiel eingibt die Adresse.
Und dass er das dann validiert und überall einträgt.
Ähm.
Ja, also vor allem, dass man halt tippen kann, was man will,
und es trotzdem funktioniert.
Also der Witz ist ja, dass man eingeben kann,
Zeil, Fra 1 und solche Dinger.
Und wenn man Glück hat, funktioniert es.
Ich bin bei Google nicht so ganz konsistent.
Zumindest, ich will eigentlich gucken,
was es kostet, zu mir schicken zu lassen.
Ja, ja, nein.
Ich will einfach nur gucken, was es kostet.
Phone.
Leute, ich will euch weder scammen, noch sonst was.
Äh, äh, äh, exa, äh, ba, irgendwas.
Ich will einfach nur gucken, was es kostet.
Blob.
Okay.
Kostet.
Das ist ja günstig.
Das ist ja richtig.
Das kostet ja innerhalb von Deutschland mehr zu verschicken.
Dank dir habe ich jetzt einen Mikrotik-Router und einen Switch.
Das Ding läuft aber noch nicht.
Da kann ich aber nichts für, dass es nicht läuft.
Wobei, die Dinger, die kommen doch sogar mittlerweile mit einem Einrichtungswizard.
Da kann man doch basic Sachen, basic config ist doch mittlerweile total einfach.
Fünf Dollar, äh, fünf Pfund.
Geht doch eigentlich.
Das heißt, ich bezahle 100 Pfund, fünf Stück.
100 zu Euro.
Zu Euro.
110 Euro.
Das ist doch okay.
Das ist doch in Ordnung, da kann man sich nicht beschweren.
110 Euro.
Ist doch okay.
Ich habe auch erstmal ein paar wieder.
Ihr kennt ja meine Regel, man bestellt nie eins.
Immer mindestens drei besser fünf bei Elektrogramm.
Gut, Sophos ist aber auch ein bisschen was anderes.
Sophos ist ja auch kein Switch oder kein Router.
Sophos ist eine Security Appliance.
Ähm, Moment.
Was haben wir hier für eine Frage?
Kleine Off-Topic-Frage.
Ich habe beim Zocken öfter Lackspikes.
Nach einem Router-Reset läuft alles wieder.
Allerdings muss ich das manchmal zweimal am Tag machen.
Ich glaube eher, das liegt an Unity Media.
Aber ja, es könnte tatsächlich daran liegen,
weil die Unity Media Connect Box absoluter Rotz ist.
Aber ich glaube eher nicht daran, dass es daran liegt.
Aber das ist reines Glaskugellesen.
Wenn man das Google API-Dings benutzt, ist es recht... Ja, das stimmt.
Das, was es bei uns kompliziert macht, ist nicht das Google API-Dings,
sondern dass ich Adress Completion über das Google API-Dings mache,
allerdings die restliche Routenberechnung über OpenStreetMaps Routing-Maschinen.
Open... Nee.
Open... Doch, ich glaube OpenStreetMaps Routing-Maschinen heißt das Ding.
Und das macht es ein bisschen komplizierter.
Ja, manche sind halt heute schon ganz scharf drauf, dass du was...
Ja, für die ist das Kohle, ne?
Hatte ich aber auch schon manchmal.
Da gehst du auf irgendeine... Ich glaube hier bei denen hatte ich das.
Bei denen hatte ich das, glaube ich, letztens... Shop, wie ist sie denn?
Hier, bei denen hatte ich das, glaube ich, letztens.
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ob das die waren.
Da habe ich auch... Alter, sieht die Seite im Darkreader hässlich aus.
Da habe ich auch letztens was in Warenkorb gelegt
und bin dann zwei Tage später wieder auf die Seite gegangen.
Da hat er gesagt, ah, sie haben noch unbearbeitete Bestellung.
Da habe ich gesagt, was?
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass ich bei euch irgendwas bestellen wollte.
Moment, ihr müsst hier auch an mich weitergeben.
Ah, gut.
Aber das ist wirklich glaskuglesen hier.
Die Geschichte, mit was da irgendwelche Lackspikes verursachten und sonst was.
Also, ich weiß aus eigener Erfahrung, dass Vodafone Unity Media,
dass da ziemlich viel Bullshit am Laufen ist.
Bei mir haben sie es jetzt auf die Reihe gekriegt,
nachdem ich öffentlich auf Twitter lange genug geflammt habe.
Und...
Ich habe auch die Unity Media Connect Box noch dran.
Ich spiele ja schon länger mit dem Gedanken, mir eine Kabelmodel im Fritzbox zu holen.
Weil aktuell habe ich halt die Unity Media Connect Box dran
und noch mal eine billige Fritzbox hinten dran für VoIP und Deckt.
Was haben die eigentlich?
Haben die eigentlich was Neues?
Zeig mal her, ich muss doch gerade mal gucken, wenn wir schon dabei sind.
Was für Hersteller kannst du zu Hause empfehlen? Netzwerksachen?
Unify, Gedöns für Access Points und MikroTick für Switche und Router.
Wobei ich selbst einen Ubiquiti 10G-Switch habe.
Kann man auch empfehlen.
Aber so über den Daumen gepeilt kann man eigentlich schon sagen.
Switch, Router, MikroTick, Access Points, Ubiquiti.
Und naja gut, als Modem und Multifunktionsverschnitt gibt es, finde ich, nichts besseres als eine Fritzbox.
Haben die eigentlich irgendwas gescheites für Kabelmoder mittlerweile?
Die Seite sieht auch übelst kacke mit dem Darkreader aus.
So, Fritzbox, Kabel.
Moment.
Cable.
Das hat alles keinen Cable, das ist DSL.
Bis dran, das liest sich so armselig mittlerweile.
Wisst ihr, vor 8 Jahren oder so, oder so mal 2010, konnten die noch mit 300 MBit irgendjemand hinter Montag vorlocken.
Aber mittlerweile liest sich das einfach echt arm.
Da sieht man mal, dass das Kupfergeschiss echt am Ende ist.
300 MBit, Alter, was ist das?
Damit kannst du ja noch nicht mal, oder damit kannst du mit Aro und Krach, DSL kann nicht mehr.
Zumindest nicht über die Kabel, die sie da gerade haben.
Und DSL ist ja auch keine Zukunftstechnik in dem Sinn.
Schon lange nicht mehr.
DSL ist eine Technik, um aus der veralten Infrastruktur noch irgendwie was Brauchbares rauszuholen.
Dass die Leute nicht von heute auf morgen mit der harten Realität konfrontiert werden.
Dass wir es in Deutschland seit 30 Jahren mit dem Ausbau komplett von A bis Z verschissen haben.
Über Kabel gehen auch viel mehr als 500.
Die Coax-Kabel haben noch eine ganze Ecke mehr Spielraum, was Bandbreite angeht.
Allerdings die Anbieter nicht.
Wenn du dir anguckst, was Vodafone und Unity Media jetzt schon für Probleme haben.
So.
300 MBit ist halt voll der Witz.
Du kannst mit 300 MBit noch nicht immer, wenn du angenommen, man hätte wirklich so eine Standardfamilie.
Irgendwie so eine theoretische Familie.
Vater, Mutter, zwei Kinder.
Wenn dort wirklich jeder das Internet nutzt, so wie man das 2020 benutzt,
dann haben die, da können die durchaus in den Abendstunden Probleme haben.
Weil ich meine, es sind 300 MBit.
Download.
Wir reden ja hier, was haben die für ein Upload bei, bei, okay, das ist VDSL.
VDSL 50, oder?
Also was hat ein VDSL 50?
Das ist alles im Rahmen, das reicht eigentlich alles mehr oder weniger.
Aber es nimmt ja immer mehr zu.
Die Leute sünden sich immer mehr Sachen in die Cloud.
Die Leute benutzen immer mehr Streaming-Sachen.
Dass heute mal irgendwie einer was hochlädt, ist ja auch nicht mehr so utopisch.
Es werden zig Filme geschert, irgendwelche Geburtstagsgeschichten geschert.
Also Bandbreite an sich ist hier bei uns wirklich gerade so, gerade so noch, gerade so.
Ja, und außerdem ist es bis zu 300 MBit.
Wir haben es einfach extrem verschissen die letzten 20, 30 Jahre.
Das hat vor 30 Jahren schon angefangen.
Also was kostet so ein Kabelding?
Blablabla, kostet, was kostet denn das?
6, 5, 6, 1, ne ich hab nicht gehofft, wie hieß das Ding jetzt?
6, 5, 9, 1, 6, 5, 9, 1.
Fritzbox, so.
Kost?
Nicht lieferbar.
Dafür kriege ich ja schon den Vera Joker Maul-Ring-Schlüssel-Satz.
Hm.
Sonst noch?
6.000.
Moment.
Ist die, ist das Ding schlechter als das da von der Nummer her?
Okay, ich brauch mal einen Vergleich.
Vergleich, Vergleich, Vergleich.
Oh Chat, ich hab euch gerade zugemacht, ich seh euch nicht.
Vergleich.
Haben die nicht irgendeinen Vergleich bei sich auf der Seite?
Okay.
Fritzbox Vergleich.
Aha, hier.
So.
Ich brauch Kabel.
Oh.
WLAN davon verwende ich eh nicht.
Juckt mir nicht.
Das hat 2,5 Gigabit LAN.
Hm.
Wozu?
Chat, ich seh euch mittlerweile wieder.
Vielleicht, wenn man, ja wozu?
Ganz ernsthaft, wozu?
Zumal es auch nur ein Gigabit LAN-Anschluss ist.
Vielleicht von dort auf irgendeinen Switch mit,
ne, keine Ahnung, verstehe nicht.
Oh guck mal, die haben noch einen ISDN intern.
Brauche ich eigentlich nicht.
Hat jemand von euch in letzter Zeit mal mit Vodafone das gemacht,
dass man seinen eigenen Router verwenden kann?
Wie, wie macht man das bei denen eigentlich?
Geht das über den Twitter-Support, muss man da irgendwie anrufen oder so?
Was ist das, was du hier gepostet hast?
Guck mal her.
Verzögerung beim Recht auf schnelles Internet.
Doch, es gibt Widerstand.
Warum gibt es bei sowas Widerstand?
Ah, es geht online, okay.
Ja, es geht online.
Also, okay, was, was, was gibt es hier Interessantes Neues?
Ähm, die Bundesminister für Wirtschaft, Verkehr, bla, bla, bla
haben ihr Referentenwurf für eine neue große Reform
des Telekommunikations an euch und unter anderem eingearbeitet.
Eigentlich sollte der auf 5, ne, auf 415 Seiten,
aber das Zeug ist mittlerweile so kompliziert, da blickt keine Sau mal durch.
Okay, doch daraus wird nichts.
Ja, das wäre ja auch was, wenn sich da irgendwas tun würde.
Wie soll sich da, wie soll sich da was tun?
Ähm, das wäre, das wäre unerhört, wenn wir auf einmal hier flächendeckt schnell Internetanschlüsse hätten.
Modem bekommst du kostenlos gestellt und beklemmst halt einfach den Router, den du willst.
Ja, Moment, das habe ich ja jetzt schon, aber da sind immer noch zwei Geräte.
Ich wollte ja nur ein Gerät.
Weil es einfach Strombesparender ist.
Weil, warum soll ich zwei Geräte anschließend noch mit einem Gerät machen kann?
So, ist das vor allem innerhalb des Bundes hier noch umstritten?
Eieiei, warum ist das denn umstritten schon wieder?
Sicherheitsfragen haben sie Bedenken, okay.
Auch das Bundesjustizministerium blockiert offenbar das weitere Verfahren,
das auf faire Verbraucherbedingungen setzt und die maximale Laufzeit von Handy und Internetvergabe mit einer eigenen Initiative...
Ja, was hat denn das eine mit dem anderen zu tun?
Boah, was? Telekommunikationsmodernisierungsgesetz.
Ah ja, alles klar.
Exzellent.
Deutschland dürfte aber ohne...
Okay, was wollen sie denn? Was ist denn das Nebenkostenprivileg?
Dass sich die EU zu einer Gigabit-Gesellschaft entwickeln kann.
Manchmal würde ich mir echt wünschen, dass ein bisschen mehr gemacht wird.
Aber ich glaube, das ist ein bisschen zu viel.
Ich glaube, das ist ein bisschen zu viel.
Manchmal würde ich mir echt wünschen, dass ein bisschen mehr gemacht wird und weniger geschwätzt.
Ja, aber das wird ja auch mal echt Zeit.
Das ist ein Unding, dass das jetzt nicht schon so ohne Probleme geht.
Ich meine, du kannst jetzt auch schon sagen, okay, diese Punkte sind strittig, die bezahle ich nicht, aber die Unstrittigen bezahle ich und so.
Aber es ist ein Riesenakt.
Es wird ja auch mal echt Zeit, dass man für was, was nicht erbracht wird, nicht bezahlen soll.
Den Grünen reicht das.
Es ist doch scheißegal, ob es ihnen nicht ausreicht.
Es ist doch schön und gut, wenn man Anfang gemacht wird.
So, zudem bei Störungen oder im Falle von versäumten Kundendiensten...
Ja, natürlich, das ist immer so der Witz.
Es ist ja jetzt auch schon teilweise so, aber das muss einfacher werden.
Ja, okay, jetzt kommt das interessante.
Recht auf Stellen des Internets.
Ein weiteres Kernvorhaben ist es, das von der Großen Koalition geplante Recht auf der Stelle Internets für alle Bürger einzuführen,
um in die soziale und wirtschaftliche Teilhabe...
Ja, okay, bla, bla, bla.
Mehrheit der Verbraucher benutzte Mindestbandbreite.
Also, was? 5 MBit?
Das Problem ist nicht so sehr, dass die Oma um die Ecke mit 5 MBit auskommen würde,
sondern da hängen ja ganze Existenzen teilweise dran.
Okay, da ist sehr viel heiße Luft um mich.
Wichtige Impulse, das ist auch so eine Hülse.
So eine Worthülse für alles Mögliche.
Wichtige Impulse für einen schnellen und flächendeckenden Ausbau von Gigabitnetzen setzen.
Wollten die nicht 50 MBit für jeden bis 2016 machen?
Auf Messengerdienste wie WhatsApp kommen bei Interoper...
Was?
Was hat WhatsApp jetzt mit schnellem Internet zu tun?
Verstehe nicht.
Glasfaserbaumaßnahmen sollen durch vereinfache Genehmigungsverfahren gestärkt...
Also, manchmal muss man sagen, finde ich die chinesische Herangehensweise bei solchen Dingern auch gar nicht so verkehrt.
Könnt ihr euch noch an das Bild erinnern, wo die das Krankenhaus gebaut haben in zwei Wochen?
Ich meine, es waren mehr oder weniger ein paar Container aufeinander,
wobei das den Krankenhaus in den letzten zwei Wochen nicht so verkehrt war.
wobei das die Leute, die drinnen behandelt wurden, wahrscheinlich nicht großartig interessiert hat.
In zwei Wochen würde das bei uns dauern, bis derjenige eventuell mal in den Antrag reingeschaut hat,
bis der Antrag überhaupt im Briefkasten liegt, wo er auf den Schreibtisch mal zugestellt wird,
wird das bei uns zwei Wochen dauern.
Da gab es doch dieses Bild aus China, wo die das Krankenhaus gebaut haben,
wo 50 Bagger einfach nur sinnlos gebaggert haben, wo man auch kein System darin erkannt hat,
Hauptsache, wir baggern mal.
Das Problem, wie die das in China am Hand haben, ist halt, dass sie das dann ohne Rücksicht auf Verluste machen.
Wenn dort mal irgendeiner zufälligerweise von Bagger fällt,
dann kriegt er wahrscheinlich als einziges eine Belobigung heim,
wo die Familie erklärt kriegt, er ist heldenhaft im Dienst des Vaterlandes gestorben.
Und fertig aus. Vorbei. Vom Bagger überfahren. Scheiß drauf.
So ein Zwischending wäre ganz gut.
Dass Sachen nicht fünf Jahre dauern und dann hat sich ein Meter bewegt,
aber ohne Rücksicht auf Verluste müsste auch nicht sein.
So ein Zwischending wäre, glaube ich, gar nicht verkehrt.
So ein bisschen wie die das in Südkorea gemacht haben mit dem Internetausbau.
Südkorea ist nicht ganz so groß wie Deutschland, so ungefähr die Hälfte, vielleicht Drittel bis Hälfte.
Was ein ewig langes sinnloses Rumgeschwätze, ey.
Meine Güte, da krieg ich wieder Anfälle, wenn ich den Scheiß lese.
Können wir eigentlich irgendwas Zukunftsmäßiges auf die Reihe kriegen?
Irgendwas. Irgendwas, wo ich sehe, okay.
Was, wo ich quasi als technisch versierter Mensch schon seit 20 Jahren denke,
Alter, gibt es das bei uns jetzt auch mal? Nein, gibt es nicht.
Ich habe letztens über, Doku kann man es nicht nennen, so eine Art Doku gesehen,
über Japan und zwar das hier, das da.
Übrigens echt unterhaltsam kann man sich angucken, wenn es einem gerade mal langweilig ist.
Und da waren die Essen in einem Sushi-Restaurant.
Warte mal, ich muss mal kurz Licht anmachen.
Warte mal, what the fuck?
Das da, genau. Ich muss mal kurz Licht anmachen.
So, und wie gesagt, das ist eine Doku, ich glaube sechs Teile oder so.
Und die waren, ich muss nur eine Sache erzählen, die waren in einem Sushi-Restaurant.
Und da ist mir mal aufgefallen, dass in Japan die Zukunft eigentlich nicht mehr so ist,
da ist mir mal aufgefallen, dass in Japan die Zukunft einfach schon da ist.
Die sind Sushi essen gegangen in so einem typischen Running-Sushi-Laden,
also sprich, was es mittlerweile auch in Deutschland gibt, so ein Sushi-Laden,
wo halt Fließbänder durchläuft. So, nur mit dem Unterschied, bei uns sitzen halt Leute in der Küche
und machen halt Running-Sushi, dort läuft das anders, dort läuft das anders,
hier ist das mit dem Fließband, dort läuft das anders.
Du sitzt in der Kabine, bestellst auf einem Tablet dein Sushi
und du hast so eine Art Hyperspeed-Fließband neben dir zu deinem Platz
und die haben auf ihrem Tablet bestellt und dann hat es, keine Ahnung, 20 Sekunden gedauert,
dann ist ihr Sushi-Teller auf in atemberaubendem Speed auf diesem High-Speed-Band rangeflitzt
und danach haben die erklärt, wie das Ganze funktioniert und zwar
die Küche besteht dort zur Hälfte aus Roboter, das heißt, das Sushi wird zum größten Teil geformt
von einem Roboter und nur die Garnierung wird von einem Menschen gemacht, also sprich,
die drücken auf einem Tablet, ich hätte jetzt gerne irgendwie 2 Sushi-Rollen mit Avocado, Lachs und sonst was,
drücken die auf ihrem Tablet, dann geht das in die Küche, der Roboter macht,
flupp, Sushi, dann kommt ein Typ an, macht die Garnierung, Teller, 15 Sekunden später ist das Ding am Platz
So, und das ging ja danach noch weiter, es wird noch viel geiler, es wird noch viel geiler
Danach, ich meine, in Japan sind die Leute eh schon relativ ordentlich, aber danach, um die Leute quasi anzuregen,
dass die ihre Sushi-Teller wegstellen, gibt es ein zweites Band, das ist quasi unterm Tisch,
wirfst du deinen Teller in so einen Schlitz und dahinter ist wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen Wasser,
dass das dann in die Küche gespült wird, die Teller, und für jede 5 Teller, die du in den Müll wirfst,
nimmst du einem Gewinnspiel teil und kannst noch Nachtisch gewinnen.
Das ist übrigens nice, perfekt, oder? Also sprich, die Leute bestellen von einem Tablet,
das Essen wird zur Hälfte von einem Roboter zubereitet, du hast eine atemberaubende Geschwindigkeit am Platz
und du kriegst noch quasi einen Anreiz, dass du deinen Müll wegräumst, das ist mal richtig Big Brain
Ja, und so was, so habe ich mir gedacht, okay, die Japaner haben es geschafft, die sind endlich,
die sind halt 2020, weil die Japaner haben einen Vorteil gegenüber uns, die haben schon begriffen,
dass das bei ihnen ähnlich läuft wie bei uns, also sprich, dass es immer weniger Jüngere gibt und immer mehr Ältere
und die sagen halt, okay, wir setzen nicht auf Einwanderung, sondern wir setzen auf massiv viele Roboter
und es kommt nicht von ungefähr, dass diese ganzen News über Robben kuscheltiere im Altersheim und so,
dass die immer aus Japan kommen, die wissen auch warum, weil die brauchen das,
denen bleibt ja gar nicht viel anderes übrig und die sind in vielen Sachen wirklich einfach
meilenweit vorne und wir wurschteln uns hier einen ab mit solchen Geschichten
Tja, was hältst du von bedingungslosem Grundeinkommen, wenn bald mal alles automatisiert ist?
Ich finde das an sich ist eine interessante Idee, ich weiß nicht genau, wie man das richtig finanzieren sollte,
aber irgendwie in diese Richtung könnte ich mir vorstellen, wird es gehen,
weil was willst du sonst mit den Leuten machen, wenn die den ganzen Tag daheim sitzen?
Also wenn wirklich mal der Fall eintreten sollte in 40 Jahren,
wobei es wahrscheinlich schneller gehen wird als uns lieb ist, dass du vielleicht noch Programmierer brauchst,
aber kein PC-Support mehr, dass du vielleicht noch irgendwelche Cloud-Engineer-Leute brauchst oder sonst was,
aber halt keinen oder zum größten Teil oder nur noch viel viel weniger Leute in irgendeiner Fabrik stehen oder so,
dann ist halt echt die Frage, was machst du denn mit 60% Arbeitslosen?
Das sind eigentliche Fragen, ich habe darauf keine Antwort, ich habe mich damit auch viel zu wenig beschäftigt,
ich kenne die Diskussion über das Grundeinkommen, ich finde das ist eine interessante Idee,
wenn man mal ehrlich ist, sind das jetzt eigentlich die Fragen, die wir uns jetzt stellen müssen?
2020 und nicht erst 2050 oder 2040, wenn es uns so geht,
da sind eigentlich Fragen, die man sich jetzt stellen müsste, wie gehen wir damit um?
Aber ich wette mit euch, wir fahren komplett gegen die Wand, wie bei so ziemlich allem, was mit Fortschritt zu tun hat.
Ja und deswegen, ich bin echt begeistert, was man so teilweise aus anderen Ländern an Fortschritt sieht
und da denke ich mir immer, ich würde mir wünschen, dass wir das heute hier auch mal ein bisschen besser machen,
ansonsten finde ich es hier echt nicht verkehrt, ich bin ja niemand, der sagt, oh das ist hier so scheiße,
ich persönlich lebe gerne hier, ich finde es super, ich könnte mir das in keinem anderen Land vorstellen zu leben,
ich finde es hier an sich toll, aber es gibt viele Sachen, wo ich mir erstens Gedanken mache,
dass die auf Dauer nicht gut gehen und wo ich mir halt denke, im Vergleich zu anderen Ländern,
wie können wir da so hinten dran sein?
Und dazu kommt auch noch das, was das Norlag sagt, wir sind eher in vielen Bereichen nicht einfach nur jetzt hinten dran,
dadurch, dass wir in vielen Bereichen jetzt hinten dran sind, werden wir in vielen Bereichen der Zukunft noch viel mehr hinten dran sein.
Es fängt mit Internet an, es geht mit Forschung, was Lebensmittel angeht weiter,
es geht mit Forschung, was erneuerbare Energien angeht weiter, es gibt so viele Sachen, zum Beispiel ist davon auszugehen,
dass wenn alle Inder und Chinesen jetzt immer einen immer weiter besseren Lebensstandard bekommen
und die früher 80% vegetarisch gelebt haben, wenn die jetzt anfangen,
auch alle so viel Fleischfutter zu wollen wie wir, dann ist die ganz große Frage, wo kriegen wir den ganzen Kram her?
Ihr meint, wir können Schafe auf dem Mond züchten oder sonst was, keine Ahnung, irgendwo muss der ganze Kram herkommen.
China und gerade Indien, also Indien und gerade China oder viele asiatische Länder haben sich die vergangenen 50 Jahre
mehr oder weniger 90% von Reis, Pflanzen, sonst was Zeug ernährt.
Da wurde zwar auch Fleisch gefuttert, allerdings bei weitem nicht in der Menge,
sondern es ist natürlich eine der großen Fragen, die sich stellen wird, ist, wie kriegt man die Leute alle satt?
Wenn alle Chinesen in der und sonst aufstrebenden Länder genauso viel Fleisch futtern wie wir, ist die Frage, wo kriegt man das her?
Und ich bin niemand, der den Leuten ausreden will, Fleisch zu essen, es gibt eigentlich nur zwei Varianten, die ich sehe.
Erste Variante ist, die Leute essen weniger Fleisch, da bin ich ja persönlich kein Fan von, weil ich esse eigentlich ganz gern Fleisch.
Die zweite Variante ist, man muss gucken, wo man das Fleisch herkriegt und es gibt einige Forschungsansätze,
dass man eben Fleisch herstellt, ohne dass man Tiere dafür braucht.
So abartig das jetzt erst mal klingt zu verzehren, würde das doch viele Probleme lösen.
Erstens, du müsstest keine Tiere mehr schlachten, wenn du Fleisch so herstellen könntest.
Du könntest es mit Sicherheit effizienter anbauen als jetzt und du hättest weniger Umwelteinflüsse auf das Ganze.
Das hätte schon seine Vorteile, wenn man Fleisch irgendwie künstlich produzieren könnte.
Das wäre nicht verkehrt und das wird auch die einzige Möglichkeit sein,
wenn in der Chinesen, viele asiatische Länder oder aufstehende Länder jetzt anfangen, so viel Fleisch zu futtern, die Leute satt zu kriegen.
Außerdem würde es noch weniger Methan und Geduld ausstoßen.
Das sind zum Beispiel, worauf ich raus will, dass wir dort auch komplett den Anschluss verlieren.
Dass wir gerade in solchen Gebieten, wir sind nur mal ein Land, was nicht durch Rohstoffe oder so großartig Kohle macht,
sondern durch Köpfchen und die Sachen in die Welt verkaufen.
Wie sollen wir das in Zukunft noch machen, wenn wir nichts mehr machen, was jemand haben will?
Außer halt die neuen Chinesen werden, möglichst billig.
Es hat übrigens, das ist jetzt eine ganz gewagte These, ich weiß und ich muss auch gleich dazu sagen, Disclaimer,
ich habe mich nicht damit beschäftigt, keine Ahnung, ob das wirklich stimmt,
aber ich könnte mir vorstellen, es kommt nicht von ungefähr, dass Tesla gerade in Deutschland ein neues Werk baut.
Vielleicht hat sich da jemand von euch mit beschäftigt, ich würde mich mal interessieren.
Das hat auch mit Sicherheit was damit zu tun, dass Arbeitskraft in Deutschland teilweise echt billig zu bekommen ist.
Also für europäische Verhältnisse, für erste Weltverhältnisse.
Hast du schon mal Fleischalternativen ausprobiert? Ja, ich habe mal einen Beyond Meat Burger gefuttert, ging, ging.
Man muss ehrlich sagen, mit ordentlich Soße und sonst was drauf, hätte man das nicht gewusst,
hätte man sich vielleicht gefragt, so ein bisschen komische Konsistenz hat das Ganze, aber eigentlich kaum Unterschied.
Sogar besser, eigentlich mal ganz ehrlich, eigentlich sogar fast besser.
Wenn man nicht so sehr darauf festgefahren ist, dass es halt ein Rinderfleisch Burger sein muss.
Na gut, Preis-Leistung der Arbeitskraft stimmt. Ja, gehe ich auch mal von aus, dass das der Grund sein wird.
Ja, und lange Rede, kurzer Sinn, das sind eigentlich Fragen, wo man sich jetzt mit beschäftigen müsste,
aber wir kriegen ja noch nicht mal hin, dass die Grundlage aller Grundlagen, nämlich Internetanbindung, mal gescheit gelöst ist.
Das ist ja die Grundlage für jede weitere technische Entwicklung, dass die Leute daran teilhaben können.
Oder dass es überhaupt mal Internetunternehmen in Deutschland gibt, die in diesem Bereich was machen,
die brauchen erstmal einen Anschluss, ordentlichen. Das ist ja die Grundlage für alles und selbst das kriegen wir schon immer gebacken.
Ja, und da sehe ich in Zukunft nicht viel, wo wir da noch großartig mitmachen können, da müssen wir echt gucken.
So, gut, also muss ich immer mal beim Einkaufen stehen geblieben. Ach ja, stimmt, was ich noch mal gucke.
Gibt es, ich bin nämlich gerade am überlegen, ich will keinen Werkzeugschrank, keinen klassischen Werkzeugschrank.
Ich hätte gerne ein paar Plastik-Schränke mit Schubladen für Werkzeug, weil ich habe, ihr kennt ja noch das Video aus dem Flur.
Baustelle, komm mal, hier ist doch mal ein Flur, da. Also genau, hier sitze ich übrigens gerade, dort.
Dort sitze ich gerade hier, hier so, hier so. Aber das war halt noch während umgebaut wurde.
So, und hier ist halt relativ viel Platz. Aktuell steht hier gar nichts und hier ist Platz.
Ich wollte mir hier so eins, zwei, drei, vier Schränke mit Schubladen hinstellen für Werkzeug und Elektronikkrams,
dass ich das mal alles ein bisschen sortiert kriege. Und hier ist halt super, da steht es nicht im Weg und weil hier ist ja eh nichts.
Ah ja, ich sehe gerade, man sieht sogar mal, die Anfänge vom Serverraum sieht man hier glaube ich auch, guck mal.
Hier sieht man noch, noch bevor irgendwas drin stand, wie das Ganze ausgesehen hat.
Ja, hier ist das Serverraum, hier ist der Kabelkanal zu meinem Schreibtisch, hier wo ich hier stehe ist mein Schreibtisch.
Und hier hinten ist so eine Mini-Küche, das ist übrigens da hinten wo der kaputte Kühlschrank steht, wo ich letztens erzählt habe.
Da sehe ich einen Keller, das ist der erste Stock hier. Und Keller, Keller wo es da nochmal runter geht oder was.
Genau und hier ist die kleine Küche drin, das ist auch da wo die Katze immer irgendwie nachts rumgammelt.
Oh hier ist mein Special-Klo, guck mal die Anschlüsse für mein Ultra-Klo waren schon da.
Und da war aber ok die Leiter war schon drin.
Ja, das ist cool zu sehen wie das ausgeschaut hat als noch nichts drin war.
Wo ist das?
Ah, das ist hier, hier steht der Schreibtisch, hier sitze ich gerade.
Na gut, was auch immer.
Aha, passt hier ok.
Genau und deswegen suche ich sowas hier in der Richtung nur mit Schubladen hätte ich gerne.
Nur was mit Schubladen.
Schubladen, sowas hier.
Sowas hier im Prinzip genau.
Nur dass das halt mega hässlich aussieht.
Sowas hier vielleicht noch ein bisschen schöner.
Also sieht das alles hässlich aus.
Das sieht aus wie von Aliexpress oder?
Sieht aus wie von Aliexpress und umgelabelt.
Das Holz.
Das will ich mir nicht in Flur stellen, das sieht mega kacke aus.
Doch das passt, das passt.
Achso, ja gut wir müssen mal gucken, wir müssen mal gucken wie tief der hier ist.
Das stimmt.
Aber ich hab hier in der Ecke schon einen stehen und der passt.
Müsste ich mal ausmessen, müsste ich mal ausmessen wie tief das ist.
Aber das sieht, die sieht der ultra hässlich aus.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, geht mal fort, null.
Ja danke, danke.
ist wie gesagt geburtstag schon ein paar tage her ich habe es jetzt einfach nur mein titel geschrieben weil ich seitdem halt nicht online war
so ähm
das hatten wir das hatten wir das hatten wir
das hatten wir auch
Ach ja auch eine sache die ich mir auch noch überlegt habe ob man
Ob sich vielleicht ein netzwerkschrank lohnt um den an die wand im sauberraum zu hängen
Jetzt machen wir noch mal kurz das video auf
Weil hier in dem hier da sieht man es doch wunderbar hier steht ja das kleine rack
Allerdings der man sieht ja hier wenn ich da range der raum ist ziemlich hoch
Der raum ist da ich ich mache die kamera leider nicht nach oben der raum ist ziemlich hoch also das geht noch ein meter nach oben hier
Die räume sind ziemlich hoch
Ich habe mir überlegt ob es nicht sinnvoll ist dass ich weil hier neben ist der kabelkanal hier kommt der kabelkanal hier man sieht
Hier in der ecke der kabelkanal aus dem keller ob es da nicht sinnvoll ist den netzwerkschrank hin zu hängen
Und den ganzen netzwerkrahmen aus dem rack zu machen wo die server drin sind und im netzwerkschrank
an die wand zu schrauben
Hoch genug für 42 e rack wahrscheinlich ja allerdings nicht tief genug für 42 e rack
Keine ahnung das muss man jetzt überlegen ist ja auch ist ja auch wurscht
Es gibt es ansonsten noch für sachen die ich mir holen wollte
Was war es eigentlich also das werde ich mir gleich bestellen hier den vera vera joker
Den satz hier den werde ich mir gleich bestellen nach dem stream ich bin da schon ganz scharf drauf ich kann es kann es kaum abwarten
Ist der raum belüftet nein
Da ist aber auch so wenig drin dass es selbst jetzt reicht
Ja bei fragen gucken also questions
Dark reader
Exist
Exzellent
Also das hat man schon
Wann programmierst du mal wieder was ich bin gerade dabei
offstream
An meiner kamera überwachungsgeschichte weiter zu basteln aber ich glaube das ist im stream nicht so spannend
Ich habe mir so was gebastelt was meine überwachungs kameras relativ latency free anzeigen kann im browser
Habe ich euch ja schon mal gezeigt halt ohne re-encoding dementsprechend geht das nur mit den kameras die
Videos streams liefern die man auch im browser anzeigen kann
Ich bastel aktuell ein bisschen an der aufnahme
Funktion rum
Aber das ist glaube ich nicht so spannend im stream
Im stream gibt es den jetzt hier plus plus ne im leben nicht
Im leben ich
Habe mit meinem chef über workstation pro geredet er meinte zu mir dass er mir eine lizenz geben kann ist doch gut top
Also ich finde vor allem wäre es das beste desktop virtualisierungs gedöns
Auch von der anhabung ja
Ansonsten müssen wir mal gucken ob es vielleicht noch etwas kleines gibt was wir wieder überschaubar im stream zusammenprogrammieren können
Kehr
Ja es wird aber besser
Also wir hatten sehr von dem thema auch schon öfters im stream und wir hatten ein paar leute also mehr als ich dachte auch
Am start die gesagt haben bei uns
Lernt man sogar was in der schule
Rastlings das klingt nach irgendeinem rastutorial
Programmiert man den esp 32 mit sie schab nein
Das ist nur c++ das ist nur c++
Das ist nur c++
Letztens habe ich auf der straße in fax stehen sehen
Hat keiner mitgenommen es hat irgendjemand abgestellt so nach dem motto ich habe keinen bock mein müll in müll zu schmeißen
Und das fax stand da rum es hat keiner mitgenommen nicht mal die typen die sonst am sperrmüll immer die technik klauen das fax wollte
Keiner haben
Fax wollte keiner haben
Musst du noch funktionieren ja also unify access point sind wirklich super da gibt es kaum was besseres
Preisleistungsmäßig auch also
Die sind zwar ein bisschen teurer also die nur nach 15 tp link access point access points aber sowohl das management wenn man sich mal dran gewöhnt hat
Als auch qualitativ finde ich sind die
Längen besser als ein billiger tp link
Und preisleistungsmäßig sind sie auch ganz okay
Irgendwelche teuren cisco access points oder so mögen vielleicht ähnlich gut sein allerdings sind die auch eine ganze ecke teurer
Warten wir schon
Die low-cost intel gemini lake dinger
Hast du das schon gesehen nein was ist das kickstarter kann man meistens relativ bedenkenlos aufmachen
Die seite ist high highly high speed. Wow was der fack?
die seite ist high high high speed wow what the fuck
mein browser crashed alter 1ks was ist da los
hast du das interleak mitbekommen ist das denn flipper 0 open source multitool
die weiße ok ok warum immer dass ein flipper pound excellent
das heißt man kann sein tamagotchi füttern indem man wehland knackt oder
wie das ist ja mal eine exzellente idee es ist ja war ich too smart
selbst wenn er kreischt ist nicht schlimm wir sind ja alles in der vm da
passiert ja nix das interleak wahrscheinlich kommt er in den
leagues raus dass intel genauso hinten dran ist wie man denkt geheim intel
dokumenten da kommt wahrscheinlich raus dass die immer noch nicht wissen wie sie
auf sieben nanometer kommen
was
wollte mir eine webcam vor der türk und wenn das war vom letzten stream schon
wollte mir eine webcam vor der türk platzieren und das dann auf einem
tablet stream hat noch ein altes ipad hast du eine bessere idee kann man
machen kann es auch nur spory pie mit einer kleinen kamera nehmen oder in eine
billige china cam die man flaschen kann gibt es 30.000 varianten ja chat
gleich mit bestellt das ist hässlich das stelle ich mir im leben nicht in flur so
was eher so was hier auch mal so viele kleine döse hier das ist natürlich
praktisch
schon die aktuellen talks der def koch nee habe ich noch gar nicht geguckt
noch null
das hat wahrscheinlich nichts dabei was man im stream angucken kann oder ist
es bei denen auf youtube oder haben die eine liste
schedule ok die seite sieht eigentlich so heckermode aus jetzt eine schöne
übersicht das ist eigentlich der taug übersicht
youtube ist besser mal gucken ob dies geschafft haben eine technik konferenz
noch technik konferenz sein zu lassen und nicht irgendwelche dinger da rein
bringen wie beim ccc letztens das der letzte kongress der hat mich jetzt zur
hälfte überhaupt nicht mehr angesprochen
ist irgendwas spannendes bei
alter wie viel zeug laden die da hoch soll er gar nicht mehr auf der fack
ne das kann ich muss mir auf stream angucken dass jetzt zu viel
hinein ich habe noch keinen kühlschrank bestellt youtube videos ob ja ich habe
eine zweifel dass es dieses jahr was wird von essen das normalerweise im
oktober oder so nie wann ist denn das immer
oder december hier 27 30 december stimmt genau ja
mal gucken wie es damit korona ausschaut viele konferenzen steigen jetzt ja
komplett auf online only um könnte man damit in talks auch machen
ja aber ich weiß nicht ob er dieses jahr wieder ein hat wie ist er david
kiesel hat er dieses jahr wieder ein
weiß man nicht ob er dieses jahr ein hat oder wahrscheinlich nicht kann ich
jedes jahr ein raushauen
alle zweier die sollten auf twitch stream ja allerdings müsste dann ein
bisschen twitch twitch gerechtes aufbereiten der inhalte sein nicht
einfach nur bühne streben oder so sondern ein bisschen was drumherum erzählen
wobei auf twitch weiß ich twitch deutschland ist so ist ein schwieriges
ding twitch deutschland gucken die leute angel camp und nicht so was na gut
games kommen online oder games kommen das wird so der reinfall werden
wann sollten das sein 18 tage käme aus dass wir so der reinfall die machen das
einfach nur online um wichtig tun zu können
so nach dem motto sieht her wir sind relevant wir machen games kommen jetzt
online das wird absolut unsinnigste veranstaltung aller zeiten werden
ja games kommen ist genau das kommt nämlich dazu
games kommen ist vor ort schon ultra langweilig mittlerweile und jetzt rein
online ist noch eine unsinnigere veranstaltung überhaupt also wenn man
dafür tickets bräuchte dann wird es ja noch nicht mal dann dann wird es ja
weiß ja komplett tote hose
i am i am poggers müsste da i am twitch chat
blödsinn braucht keiner die 3 gab es ja dieses jahr im endeffekt auch nicht es
sind ein paar pressekonferenzen und ankündigungen streams übrig geblieben
das war es messen online ist sinnlos zumindest so was da die games kommen ist
ja zwar offiziell eine spiele messe aber inoffiziell oder was also nein
offiziell so wie sie wirklich benutzt wird ist es ja zumindest in 50 prozent
mittlerweile so ein influencer event
mit fan treffen und und typen die auf der bühne rumrennen und sonst was ja also
das ist eigentlich online komplett sinnlos ja mit fachpresse ist da auch
noch mal viel also gibt es aber ich muss ehrlich sagen
das war schon die jahre wo wir da waren echt grenzwertig und wirklich
wichtig ist erfahren hast du auch nicht das beste muss ich sagen muss ich was
wir im nachhinein muss ich sagen war war wirklich wo wir mal bei ark damals am
stand waren das war eines der wenigen fälle wo ich echt das gefühl habe hatte
dass die entwickler ihr eigenes produkt nicht nur fake geil finden sondern es
selbst also das hier meine ich sondern selbst spielen und es ihnen spaß macht
und sie ist deswegen geil finden allerdings war das bevor sie ihr
komisches piraten spiel rausgebracht haben und bevor bevor das game dann
irgendwie den bach runter ging und es war noch keine marketing leute das
gemacht haben sowas hatten die damals nicht das war wirklich zwei entwickler
die das gezeigt haben also mit dem wir da den termin hatten
zusammengesessen haben und die waren wirklich begeistert von ihrem game und
man hat ihn man hat ihn abgekauft dass sie begeistert waren es hat ihnen auch
echt spaß gemacht den kram zu spielen das hast du gemerkt das hat so bei den
anderen meistens nicht das war einfach nur marketing geblubber
ich kann mich doch alles hartlein battlefield hartlein erinnern auf der
games kommen wo wir oben drinnen waren bei ea am hartlein gespielt und dann sind
wir die treppe die rolltreppe runtergefahren und danach hat sich hinter
der rolltreppe einer angestellt an mich und hat gesagt er hat mich erkannt
ja und da hat er recht gehabt
hat er mich revealed ja einer der wenigen die mich wirklich erkannt haben
oft und das mitten auf der games kommen heute juckt das eh kein mehr so leute
wir sehen uns morgen früh beim aufwacht stream das war heute eine so spontane
geschichte trotzdem waren wir zweieinhalb stunden und ich merke dass ich bin das
gar nicht mehr so richtig gewöhnt gewöhnt
ja das hat er auch an der art und weise gemerkt ich habe gesehen ich habe ich
habe zu meinem team irgendwie gesagt im in battlefield hat alle leute wir sagen
übelst wir müssen erst mal mühe geben allergemeiner hin bis der max gibt es zu ja
stimmt ich gebe es zu so war es so ist es war es recht
die games kommen das war teilweise schon cringe da manche influencers die da am
start waren
na gut heute morgen früh aufwachen stream wie gehabt ich muss mich echt ein
bisschen dran gewöhnen dass ich wieder hier vier stunden am stück streamen
kann macht es gut wir sehen uns morgen früh
bis denn zu